Herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nr. 28. Wir wollen heute mal über die Wahlen in den USA reden, über Wahlcomputer, über Wahlfälschung und was uns da so zu erwarten hat. Dabei begrüßen wir als Gast bei uns im Studio den Rob.
Hallo.
Guten Tag. Der sich ja schon, wie einige von euch vielleicht wissen, relativ intensiv mit dem ganzen Thema Wahlcomputer auseinandergesetzt hat, insbesondere in Holland und in Deutschland.
Aber es geht nicht nur um Wahlcomputer, sondern es geht eher ums gesamte System. Denn viele von den Problemen sind eher strukturelle Probleme, die da ausgenutzt werden. Das sind gar nicht alles irgendwelche manipulierten Computer, irgendwelche Viren und Würmer in der Infrastruktur. Aber das werden wir der Reihe nach einzeln behandeln. Wir wollen wie immer anfangen mit so ein bisschen historischem Überblick. Wie sieht das System eigentlich aus? Wo kommt das her? Rob hat da mal geforscht. Erzähl mal Rob.
Naja, das US-Wahlsystem ist schon echt anders als bei uns, sowohl in Deutschland als in Holland. Holland und Deutschland sind hintereinander eigentlich ganz ähnlich. Und in Europa gibt es mehrere so halbwegs ähnliche Systeme. Das US-Wahlsystem sieht noch so ein bisschen mehr so wie England aus. Es hat Distrikte. Das Parlament ist nach Distrikten organisiert. Es gibt auf dem federalen Niveau, das wissen die meisten Leute, auch gibt es Congress und es gibt das White House. Congress ist das Parlament. Das Parlament hat zwei Kammern. Es gibt das House of Representatives. Da gibt es dann 435 Sitze, die dann jeweils einem Distrikt zugehören. Das Congressional District. Und es gibt der Senat. Da sind pro Staat, pro Bundesland gibt es dann noch mal zwei Sitze. Und dann gibt es das White House. Und das White House, da sitzen Präsident und Visepräsident. Die werden separat gewählt. Und die haben eigentlich alle Exekutivemacht.
Das heißt, dass es nicht so wie bei uns, dass es sowas wie Koalitionsregierungen geben kann, in denen halt mehrere Parteien beteiligt sind?
Nee, man gibt eine von beiden Parteien, das sind zwei Parteisystem, da kommen wir noch drauf, aber man gibt eine dieser beiden Parteien für vier Jahre eigentlich alle Macht in der Exekutive. Das Parlament kann dann trotzdem andere Parteien die Macht haben, aber in der Exekutive ist eine Partei an der Macht.
Und die Wahlen, die jetzt stattfinden am 6. November, die sind ja nicht nur Präsidentenwahlen.
Nee, es gibt sehr viel, was am gleichen Tag passiert. Dienstag, 6. November, also bald, ein Drittel der Senat wird neu gewählt. Das sind 33 Sitze. Das Haus of Representatives wird ganz neu gewählt. Das ist alle zwei Jahre.
Das wird komplett neu gewählt?
Das wird komplett neu gewählt. 11 State Governors werden neu gewählt. In sehr vielen Staaten gibt es dann auch noch mal Parlamentswahlen für das eine oder das andere oder beide Häuser. Es gibt Wahlen, für viele andere Stellen. In Amerika gibt es so der Witz, dass alles bis zur City Dog Catcher gewählt wird.
Der Hundepfänger.
Genau. Aber Richter, District Attorneys, Staatsanwälte, solche Funktionen werden da gewählt. Also ziemlich viele Stellen, auch nicht ganz wichtige. Und es wird über ganz viele Ballot-Initiatives entschieden. Wenn man eine bestimmte Anzahl Unterschriften hat, dann kriegt man ein Initiative on the Ballot.
Also was über uns eine Volksabstimmung quasi.
Was eine Volksabstimmung ist, nur die sind dann...
Das ist ja so ein Volksbegehren. Also wenn genügend viele Leute ja stimmen, dann... Also es kommt auch auf den Staat an, was dann passiert. In Kalifornien hat es dann Gesetzeskraft, aber es gibt andere Staaten, wo das dann nochmal vom Parlament behandelt werden muss.
Ja, nee, aber in vielen Staaten hat das Gesetzeskraft. Darum sind die auch teilweise wichtig. Und es gibt immer größere Support für zum Beispiel Legalisierung von Marijuana und auch für Gay Marriage. Solche Themen sind generationell. Die alten Leute sind dagegen, die jungen Leute sind eher dafür. Und umso mehr alte Leute sterben und junge Leute dazukommen, umso mehr wandert so ein Thema.
Oder andersrum, wie in Deutschland. Naja, ist ja leider so. Unsere Demografie führt ja durchaus eher dazu, dass unsere Gesellschaft konservativer wird.
Also was ich ganz wichtig finde bei den USA ist, dass es bei uns so ist, dass die Merkel mit ihrem Kabinett kann auch beim Budget Sachen entscheiden. Aber der Präsident in den USA kann es nicht, das ist die Sache des Kongresses. Das heißt, wenn Obama jetzt sagt, wir holen den Bin Laden und dafür ist kein Geld bereitgelegt, dann kann er das gar nicht machen. Der Präsident hat weniger Macht in der Praxis, als üblicherweise so angenommen wird von der Bevölkerung oder was man so aus Hollywood-Filmen kennt. Also der ist, uns heißt ja immer, der mächtigste Mann der Welt und sowas. Der machen kann es einen Raketenschlag ordern, aber er kann nicht mal eben sagen, okay wir geben jetzt mehr Geld für, was weiß ich, arbeitslose Hilfe aus oder so. Sondern das ist Sache des Kongresses.
Ja, es gibt noch andere Sachen, die beim Kongress liegen, und zwar Gesetzgebung. Bei uns, sowohl in Holland als in Deutschland, ist es so, dass die Ministerien eigentlich das Großteil der Gesetzgebung machen und Parlament das nur zustimmt oder abstimmt. Aber in Amerika ist wirklich alle Gesetzgebung wird vom Kongress gemacht.
Das heißt, die kommt auch aus dem Kongress? Die kommt aus dem Kongresse. Die Gesetzinitiativen kommen nicht über uns aus den Ministerien?
Naja, die kommen in beiden Fällen von Lobbyisten, nur halt auf einmal andere Wege.
Na gut, ich meine, bei uns sollen sie eigentlich auch aus dem Parlament kommen, nicht aus den Ministerien.
Aber das sind doch die Experten, die Fachkräfte in den Ministerien.
Stimmt, die von der Industrie aus geborgen.
Genau, Partnerschaft. Ja, also es gibt ja diverse Unterschiede, aber die Wahlen sind, was dem einen oder anderen vielleicht auffällt, an einem Wochentag. Das ist ein wichtiger Unterschied zu uns. Bei uns sind Wahlen am Sonntag, damit keiner was vorhat und hingehen kann und nicht entschieden werden muss im Einzelfall, kann ich mir das leisten, wählen zu gehen. In Amerika, ich weiß gar nicht warum, ist das aus historischen Gründen immer an einem Wochen, ich glaube, ist immer Dienstag oder Donnerstag oder so.
Ja, bei uns in Holland ist es auch am Wochentag und das ist doof, weil da muss die Wahllokale viel länger aufhalten und dafür hat man dann immer noch wenig Zugängigkeit des Wahlprozesses.
Das ist ja schon ein inherentes Problem, wenn du Wahlen am Wochentag hast, dann hast du eben das Problem in einer schwachen Wirtschaft, dass Leute mit jedem Euro oder jedem Dollar rechnen müssen und sich das möglicherweise gar nicht leisten können, wählen zu gehen. Das ist auch ein Thema zu dem wir später noch mal kommen werden, aber das ist halt in den USA üblich und man kriegt auch nicht frei am Wahltag, sondern es wird davon ausgegangen, dass man zur Arbeit erscheint. Und wer wählen geht und da mit langen Schlangen rechnen muss, muss sich halt einen Tag freinehmen und kriegt nicht bezahlt dafür.
Ja, es gibt halt viele Sachen, die in Amerika etwas anders sind. Man muss halt sagen, das System in Amerika ist im Moment in Krise. Das geht da politisch nicht gut. Es gibt noch mehr Geld in Umlauf in der Politik als vorher. Da gab es dieses Gerichtsurteil Citizens United bei der Supreme Court.
Ja, warum ging es da? Das ist ein bisschen längliche Sache, aber ich finde es wichtig, dass wir das erklären.
Ganz kurz gesagt ging es darum, ob jetzt Firmen oder kommerzielle Interessen, die sich zusammentun und ein politisches Begehren haben, ob die dafür eigentlich unendlich Geld ausgeben dürfen. Also nicht die direkte Kampagne der Kandidaten, dass die unterliegen dann zumindest auf Papier noch irgendwelche Maxima, aber dann die freie Kampagnen von irgendwelche Firmen, die irgendwelche politische Begehren haben. Und die dürfen jetzt eigentlich unendlich Geld ausgeben. Das sind die sogenannten Superpacks.
Das sind dann diese Spots, wo dann irgendwie drunter steht, die Spots wurden irgendwie...
Crossroads for America, Citizens for Blablabla.
Also historisch gesehen ist es so, dass die Parteien in den USA ihren Wahlkampf selber bezahlen. Bei uns ist es ja so, dass es auch die Parteien bezahlen, aber die kriegen das Geld zurück, je nachdem, wie viel Stimmen sie haben vom Steuerzahler. Das heißt, letztendlich kann man als Partei, wenn man grob abschätzen kann, wie viel Stimmen man kriegen kann, kann man dafür sorgen, dass man da nicht ins Minus gerät in den USA. Es ist aber so, wenn man Präsident werden will, muss man riesige Geldmengen zusammensuchen und im aktuellen Wahlkampf sind es auf beiden Seiten jeweils eine Milliarde, die da zusammengekommen sind, rund, hab ich gelesen. Also Größenordnung. Das heißt unglaubliche Geldmengen. Und historisch gesehen gab es da eben Limits, weil man nicht wollte, dass ein Paar die Wahl kaufen können, gab es ein Limit, was eine Person spenden darf. Und das waren irgendwie 2500 Dollar pro Jahr oder so. Also es ist schon relativ viel gewesen, fand ich. Aber es ist jetzt nicht genug, dass irgendwie ein Milliardär losgeht und mal eben Wahlkampf kauft. Und als Antwort darauf ist eben diese Idee des PEC entstanden. Das ist ein Political Action Committee. Das ist eine Art Verein, würde man bei uns sagen, der nicht der Partei gehört und auch nicht verwandt ist, sondern eine Privatsache ist. Und die machen dann aber Werbung für den einen Kandidaten oder den anderen. Das heißt, der Wahlkampf wird outsourced an private Interessen. Und da stand eben die Frage im Raum, soll man da nicht auch Limits drauf haben? Und überhaupt, wie ist denn das mit natürlichen Personen und Firmen? Denn Firmen sind ja juristische Personen, dürfen die auch spenden. Und das war eben die Entscheidung dann, dass der Supreme Court gesagt hat, die dürfen auch spenden. Ich finde, an der Stelle sollten wir auch The Corporation nochmal plagen. Die erzählen nämlich, wie es dazu gekommen ist, dass wir überhaupt juristische Personen haben. Da sind nämlich sehr übel.
Also juristische Personen, die natürlichen Personen gleichgestellt werden.
Genau, das war nämlich ein Missbrauch der Gesetze, die zum Schutz der befreiten Sklaven dienen sollten. Da haben Firmen dann mit diesen Gesetzen geklagt und sich so Status als juristische Personen erstritten. Und der Supreme Court hat eben in diesem Citizen United Ruling entschieden, dass juristische Personen auch spenden dürfen. Und zwar diese Idee des Super-Pack heißt eben, dass man dann wie früher eine Pack hat. Aber da kann praktisch ohne Limit von Firmen Geld eingezahlt werden. Die müssen nicht mal sagen, wer sie sind. Und die müssen noch nicht mal im Inland sein. Also es darf auch, was so einer der Witze war, die da rumging, die saudische Königshaus könnte jetzt quasi den Wahlkampf kaufen, weil die haben halt genug Kohle rumliegen. Und das Urteil ist eigentlich im In- und Ausland mit Schock aufgenommen worden. Und es gab eigentlich niemanden, der das gut fand. Und der Supreme Court findet es wohl inzwischen auch nicht mehr gut, was man so hört. Aber es ist halt nach wie vor, hat Gesetzeskraft.
Was ja auch noch interessant ist, in den USA hört man eigentlich immer nur von zwei Parteien. Also es gibt ja eigentlich nur so in der öffentlichen Darstellung, zumindest in den Mainstream-Medien, finden ja eigentlich nur die Republikaner und die Demokraten statt. Und alles andere ist eigentlich eher, ja, gibt es zwar auch noch irgendwo, aber fällt dann nur auf, wenn da mal der Kandidat verhaftet wird von den Grünen zum Beispiel, weil er eigentlich bei der Präsidentendebatte mit dabei sein wollte. Und die spannende Frage ist, wie kam es denn eigentlich dazu? Also was ist dann eigentlich der historische Hintergrund davon?
Ja, Distriktensysteme führen eigentlich zwangsläufig dazu, dass es zwei Parteiensysteme werden. Weil es nichts bringt, um 30 Prozent der Vote zu haben. Auch nicht, wenn es übers ganze Land 30 Prozent ist. Weil du dann immer noch null Sitze hast.
Wir müssen ja mal erklären, es ist halt ein Unterschied in der Auszählung. In den USA ist es so, wenn ein District-Kandidat A gewinnt, dann gehen alle Stimmen für den District an diesen Kandidaten. Und bei uns geht es ja im Proporz an die einzelnen Kandidaten. Das heißt, die haben Winner takes all System, was die Briten auch haben übrigens. Und was auch da zu demselben Problem führt, da gibt es auch andere Parteien als Labour und die Tories, aber die spielen auch keine Rolle, weil genau dieses Problem ist.
Jetzt geht es zum ersten Mal die Liberation.
Die einzigen, die jetzt mal eine Rolle spielen, und das ist auch eher geografisch, weil die wohl in Schottland sehr beliebt sind, sind die Lib Dems. Aber das ist eigentlich inhärent, wenn man so ein System hat, wo dann der gesamte District rübergeht. Das heißt, der zweite Gewinner ist halt genauso ein Verlierer wie alle anderen Verlierer, der kriegt genau gar nichts dann.
Ich meine, das muss man vielleicht mal erklären. Das Unterschied ist eben der Grund, warum es in Deutschland ja nicht nur direkt Kandidaten gibt, sondern eben auch Listenstimmen. Also bei uns bei der Bundestagswahl, wenn halt für den Bundestag gewählt wird, gibt es ja ein zweigliedriges System. Zum einen gibt es Direktkandidaten, für die man halt direkt abstimmen kann. Und wer die meisten Stimmen in den Wahlkreis kriegt, geht in den Bundestag. Und es gibt die Listenstimmen. Das heißt, man stimmt halt für eine Partei und die Stimmen werden halt bundeslandweise oder bei der Europawahl bundesweit akkumuliert. Und man muss dann nur da über die Gesamtzahl der Stimmen kommen. Und genau diesen zweiten Teil, also dieses Listensystem, gibt es in den USA nicht. Es gibt also nur ein reines Direktkandidatensystem, was dann eben dazu führt, dass eben nur dieses zwei-Partei-System ist. Muss man sich halt auch immer mal wieder überlegen. So dieses Listensystem haben wir auch schon mal eine Weile drüber diskutiert. Natürlich auch Nachteile, weil es halt Dinge wie den Fraktionszwang einfacher macht, weil natürlich die Partei sehr viel mehr Macht über einen einzelnen Abgeordneten hat, wenn sie ihm sagen kann, so alter, wenn du dich nicht benimmst im Parlament und mit uns stimmst, dann landest du nächstes Mal nicht auf einem sinnvollen Listenplatz. Was man natürlich im Direktkandidaten so nicht so ohne weiteres erzählen kann. Auf der anderen Seite würde ein reines Direktkandidatensystem dazu führen, dass wir zuständig werden, USA hätten, dass es eben nur zwei Parteien gibt. Immer mal wieder sehr wichtig, diesen direkten Vergleich zu ziehen. Noch so eine interessante Auswirkung von diesem Zweitparteiensystem ist, dass sich die gesamte Medienaufmerksamkeit konzentriert sich ja auch nahezu schon künstlich nur auf diese beiden Parteien. Selbst relativ große Dritte-Parteien wie die Grünen finden nur völlig am Rande statt. Die Präsidentendebatte wird in zwei Parteien kommitiv veranstaltet, was das Republikan und Demokraten zusammengesetzt ist. Diese Debatte organisieren die im amerikanischen Wahlkampf mit den wichtigsten Highlights, glaube ich. Ich weiß nicht, was die tatsächlich entscheiden. Ich finde, das ist ein bisschen zu sehr hochgehalbt, aber...
Nein, nichts. Das ist eine PR-Veranstaltung. Und dementsprechend, also bei uns würde sowas halt von ARD gemacht werden wahrscheinlich. Und da würde man dann einen Moderator hinsetzen, der auch peinliche Fragen stellt. Aber in den USA ist es eben so, dass das eine Wahlkampfveranstaltung ist. Und da setzt man dann eben so einen alten Sack hin, der ja und amen sagt und keine Lügen korrigiert und gar nichts macht im Wesentlichen, weil das ist nicht seine Aufgabe. Das geht nur darum, dass die sich da präsentieren können.
Das Interessante daran ist eben, dass dieses System dazu führt, dass die beiden Parteien sich auch immer ähnlicher werden. Also dass halt einfach die Unterschiede immer marginaler werden.
Bis auf den Wahlkampf. Da sind sie dann bemüht, die Unterschiede rauszuholen.
Also ich kam hier noch in einem Gespräch mit amerikanischen Freunden, die sich untereinander über einen gemeinsamen Freund unterhielten und sagten, er ist in die Partei eingetreten. Und ich fragte ja so, welche Partei denn so? Ja, The Party ist doch eh so.
Republicrats, fand ich den schönsten Namen dafür.
Die Partei halt.
Aber was man auch sagen muss, ist, dass die beiden Parteien vorher, so 70er, 80er, hat es immer Kooperationen auch noch zwischen den beiden Parteien gegeben. Das hat Fraktionen gegeben, dadurch, dass es Zentrist-Candidates gegeben hat.
Also sachbezogen Koalitionen, nicht irgendwie generell.
Genau. Das ist über Themen dann sich teilweise auch Parlamentsmitglieder, sowohl in House als Senate, von beiden Parteien zusammengetan haben über ein bestimmtes Thema. Und mittlerweile ist das so, dass zwischen Demokraten und Republicans wirklich halbwegs offener Krieg ist. Die versuchen alles voneinander zu blockieren, zu sabotieren.
Das ist auch beidseitig übrigens. Also viel von dem, was wir hier erzählen, da heißt es immer die bösen Republikaner. Aber dieser Krieg ist tatsächlich beidseitig und der liegt auch ein bisschen im System begründet. In den USA gibt es nämlich diese Idee von einem Filly Buster. Der wird dann gern benutzt, wenn man nämlich nicht die Mehrheit hat und auch nicht genug Minderheit, um ein Gesetz zu verhindern.
Im Parlament jetzt?
Im Parlament. Dann stellt man sie einfach hin und lässt die Debatte nicht enden. Das heißt, da reiht man dann einen Redebeitrag an den nächsten, bis der Termin abgelaufen ist, bis zu dem, das hätte entschieden werden müssen. Und das haben irgendwann die Demokraten angefangen zu machen unter Busch, weil sie keinen anderen Weg hatten, um da irgendwie Einfluss zu nehmen. Und das hat so gut funktioniert, dass sich das als Mem eingebürgert hat. Es geht nicht mehr darum, gute Gesetze zu machen, sondern es geht darum, dass der andere, der gerade regiert, überhaupt kein Gesetz hinkriegt, damit man im Wahlkampf sagen kann, der sei ein ineffektiver Präsident gewesen, der uns nicht vorangebracht hat.
Ja, mal grob, so wie ich jetzt die Vereinigten Staaten sehe, es gibt jetzt eine Menge Geld, was in die Politik reinfließt und es gibt eigentlich eine ganze Menge Policies, die nur noch für eine ganz kleine Schicht der Bevölkerung gut sind, die dann irgendwie von meistens Republikaner durchgepusht werden. Und dafür gibt es jetzt diese zwei komplett getrennte Realitäten auch in den Medien. Es gibt jetzt nicht mehr eine Realität, worum sich Leute streiten, ob es jetzt so ist oder so, sondern es gibt zwei komplett getrennte Realitäten. Es gibt eine republikanische Realität.
Eine Filterbubble.
Das ist so die Fox News-Realität.
Die Fox News-Realität, wo komplett andere Themen sind, wo nicht nur andere Meinung ist, sondern wo auch ganz andere Fakten sind. Und Amerikaner sind wirklich so die beiden Küsten. Da wohnen dann teilweise Demokraten. Und da würden wir uns noch einigermaßen in die politische Debatte erkennen. Und dann in der Mitte wohnen Großteilsrepublikaner und im Süden in Texas und so. Und das ist wirklich, zumindest von uns aus gesehen, wirklich ein Bubble. Da gibt es keinen Climate Change. Da ist die Welt nur 6.000 Jahre alt.
Obama ist ein Kommunist.
Obama ist ein Kommunist. Sowieso in Kenia geboren. Die Realitäten liegen echt weit auseinander. Und man kann nicht anders sagen, dass das Land darunter leitet. Das geht da nicht gut.
Das ist überhaupt ein sehr witziges Phänomen, weil genau die Staaten, also man sagt immer der Bible bellt, genau die Staaten, die so sehr fundamental christlich sind und üblicherweise Republikaner wählen in der Mitte.
Also der Bibelgürtel.
Der Bibelgürtel, ja. Das sind genau die Nutznießer von dem föderalen System im Moment. Also wenn man sich anguckt, das ist ja in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland ähnlich, gibt es halt ein paar Staaten, die zahlen ein. Und es gibt halt mehrere Staaten, die unterm Strich Geld rauskriegen. Strukturausgleich. Und das ist in Amerika nicht anders. Und das ist eben so, dass die reicheren Staaten, die einzahlenden Staaten, das sind üblicherweise die an den Küsten, wo halt mehr Handel ist mit dem Ausland, liegt ja auch auf der Hand. Und die strukturschwachen Regionen, die unterm Strich die ganzen Auszahlungen entgegennehmen, das sind genau die republikaner Staaten. Und deren zentraler Talking Point in den Wahlen ist eigentlich immer, dass der Staat reduziert werden muss und diese ganzen Auszahlungen weg müssen. Aber das wäre genau das Gegenteil dessen, was die eigentlich wollen. Das ist so ein bisschen ein Problem, wenn man als Außenstehender versucht, das System in den USA zu verstehen, weil viele von den geäußerten Standpunkten einfach überhaupt keinen Sinn ergeben, wenn man sich das so anguckt. Also das wäre, wie wenn man bei uns sagt, also bei uns ist es ja andersrum. Die Leute, die gegen diesen Strukturausgleich sind, sind Länder wie Bayern, die hauptsächlich einzahlen, die halt sagen, wir haben da nichts von, wir verlieren nur Geld, wir wollen Unabhängigkeit. Das kann man doch irgendwie rational erklären, aber wenn die Empfängerländer sagen, sie wollen raus, das ergibt ja wirklich überhaupt keinen Sinn. Und zwar aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen. Die sagen ja nicht, sie wollen raus, weil wir mögen die nicht, sondern weil wir das doof finden, wenn hier Geld vom Staat umverteilt wird. Also es gibt so eine, in deren Realität sind auch die ärmsten White-Trash-Einwohner von irgendwelchen Sumpf-Dörfern, sehen sich aber noch als die Mittelschicht, die von den bösen illegalen Einwanderern ausgenommen wird. Und was man von den Medien erwarten würde, dass man den Leuten erklärt, hört man mit deinem Gehalt, bist du aber keine Mittelschicht, sondern du bist Unterschicht, du bist der, der hier die Gelder kriegt, das findet halt nicht statt, sondern die Medien gehören Großkonzernen, die selber an den Wahlen beteiligt sind, beziehungsweise da vested interest haben, wie man so schön sagt. Und da kann man nicht erwarten, informiert zu werden, sondern da gibt es halt PR den ganzen Tag.
Ja, aber das ist auch das Geniale natürlich an der heutigen Coup. Das ist...
Das Lustige ist, dass du so immer so eine Simulation hast, als wenn Sachen noch nicht entschieden werden. Beim Rauchen gab es ja dieses Phänomen über 20 Jahre. Dadurch, dass es eine laute Minderheit gab, die behauptet hat, Rauchen würde gar keinen Krebs erzeugen, hat man, wenn man da nur eine Minute investiert hat in das Thema, hätte man zu dem Ergebnis kommen können, dass die Wissenschaft sich noch nicht einig ist. Und dieses Phänomen gibt es ja komplett für die gesamte Politik in den USA, dadurch, dass es diese zwei Realitäten gibt. Wenn man ein bisschen durch die Fernsehkanäle zappt und mitkriegt, was MSNBC, die so ein bisschen als der liberale Sender gelten, was die in den Nachrichten erzählen, zu derselben Obama-Romney-Debatte, über die auch Fox News berichtet, und die erzählen dir das exakte Gegenteil und beide haben Videoclips von ihren Realitäten, die halt geschickt zurechtgeschnitten sind, dann hat man auch den Eindruck, ja, die Frage ist wohl noch offen.
Und dann gibt es ja noch dieses schöne Some People Say Phänomen.
Ja, ja, ja, die Talking Points.
Also was mir immer so aufgefallen ist, dass irgendwie so im Vergleich zu hier die Wahlen in Amiland ja doch eher ganz schön dreckig sind. Also das ist halt einfach irgendwie sowohl so, was so schwarze Propaganda angeht als auch irgendwie Angriffs-Spots und so, also halt einfach irgendwie...
Swift Boat.
Ja, die andere Seite so richtig in den Dreck gezogen wird und so.
Das liegt an den Packs. Das machen halt nicht die Kandidaten selber, sondern die haben sich da...
Ja, das gab es immer schon.
Deniability aufgebaut.
Nein, nein, nein, das war schon immer so.
Ja, natürlich. Aber die Packs sind richtig alt. Die Super Packs sind neu. Packs gibt es schon ewig lang.
Ja, aber der Stil ist trotzdem...
Der Stil wird immer dreckiger. Dann kann man bald wieder mit durchfahren.
Und ich meine, die Packs sind ja auch dann nur Instrumente. Also am Ende ist ja schon die Politik selber, die so...
Es gibt schon so einen schönen amerikanischen Satz, vote early and vote often.
Das wird gern an R.
Capone zugeschrieben.
Ja, wird gern an R. Capone zugeschrieben. Ist schon etwas älter. Aber so Anfang 20. Jahrhundert, 1910, als diese ganzen Kriminellen in Chicago und sonst wo unterwegs waren...
Es ging um Bürgermeisterwahlen, wenn ich es richtig erinnere.
Ja, da hat es einige Unregelmäßigkeiten schon gegeben. Und da waren Wahlen auch damals schon zu kaufen und war schon eigentlich alles, was es jetzt an Dirty Tracks gibt. Eine Menge davon, auch wenn es um digitale Tricks geht, eine Menge davon kommt im Urform aus solcher Zeitalter. Und die ganze Gedanke, die wir hier haben, dass die Wahlen von einer unparteiligen Bürokratie veranstaltet werden und dass man die vertrauen muss, das war da immer schon so, dass die Encompass die Macht hatten und die nicht loswerden wollten.
Also Encompass sind die, die schon gerade an der Macht sind.
Und dass die das so organisiert haben, dass es möglichst so bleibt.
Die Statistik ist übrigens ausgesprochen krass an der Stelle. Wenn man sich anguckt, wie häufig der Encompass wiedergewählt wird, dann kommt man bei den Gouverneuren auf eine Quote von 90 Prozent oder so. Die sind alle, fast ihr gesamtes Leben bleiben, die im Amt, wenn die einmal Gouverneur geworden sind. Eben weil die Strukturen so ausgelegt sind, dass es sehr schwierig ist, so jemanden aus seinem Posten rauszudringen. Und mit den Sitzen im Abgeordnetenhaus sieht das natürlich ähnlich aus. Die Senatoren sind auch alles alte Leute. Als Parallele würde ich da immer gerne die Börse nehmen. Da ist es auch so, dass man so einen Börsenplatz traditionell geerbt hat.
So einen Börsenmarkler?
Den konnte man halt nicht kaufen.
Börsenmarklerplatz?
Genau, so einen Platz als Börsenmarkler an einem New York Stock Exchange konnte man auch nicht kaufen. Sondern da gab es halt n von, und wenn einer gestorben ist, dann hat er das dann seinen Sohn übergeben. Und so ähnlich läuft es in der Politik eben auch. Die Tricks sind alt, aber wir haben eben neue Methoden, um sie mit neuer Intensität anzuwenden. Das ist eben die elektronische Datenverarbeitung, hilft da genau wie an allen anderen Stellen der Gesellschaft. Man kann sich eben heute von Facebook die Daten kaufen, um zu einem Namen aus dem Wählerregister entscheiden zu können.
Genau, wie viel Schulden der hat. Halt, Moment, wir sollten mit diesem Wählerregister nochmal klären, weil das gibt es ja hier auch nicht. Was ist die Bedeutung für diesen?
Ja, na ja, doch, natürlich.
Also hier hast du einen direkten Personalsweis. Na ja, hier hast du einen direkten Personalsweis, aber in den USA registriert man sich ja für eine Partei als Wähler.
Na, du musst dich erstmal generell für eine Wahl, also die Partei spielt eigentlich keine große Rolle, die du da angibst. Aber wichtig ist, dass du registriert sein musst. Und dass die Partei dransteht, liegt daran, dass die Parteien diese Registrierung gerne vornehmen im Wahlkampf. Das heißt, die gehen rum und sie möchten auch für Romney wählen. Und wenn du dann Ja sagst, dann kriegst du von ihnen Zettel, mit dem du dich registrieren kannst. Da geht es aber nicht darum, quasi... Na gut, aber wenn du nicht registriert bist, dann kannst du nicht wählen, genau. Und das liegt daran, dass sie keinen Pass haben.
Kannst du gar nicht wählen oder?
Nee, dann kannst du nicht wählen. Du musst registriert sein. Lustigerweise ist das ganze System so ein System, wo man als Europäer sagen würde, das kann doch gar nicht funktionieren. Wenn man jetzt, sagen wir mal, in Washington State, da hab ich mir das mal erklären lassen, von einem, der da wohnt, im Wählerregister ist, dann kann man aber auch in jedem Wahllokal im Staat wählen. Also man muss da nicht bei sich zu Hause wählen, wie bei uns. Es gibt auch eine Briefwahl, aber ich hab gefragt, naja, wie verhinderst du denn, dass jemand dann einfach bei zwei Wahllokalen wählt? Und dann meint die, naja, das ist halt verboten. Da kommt man dann in den Knast, wenn das rauskommt. Und dann meine ich, naja, wie findest du das raus? Ja, äh, also das gesamte System ist irgendwie so, äh, was?
Vote early and vote often.
Ja, es klingt alles nach Air Capone. Und ich hab mich dann schon gefragt, naja, dann muss es doch enorme Probleme mit Wahlbetrug geben. Aber die Statistik sagt, nein, gibt's nicht. Ich mein, gut, das kann jetzt daran liegen, dass es im Einzelfall dann auch schwer nachzuweisen wäre. Aber der Statistik nach gibt es so gut wie überhaupt keinen Wahlbetrug.
Also kein Double-Voter-Betrug.
Also man muss mal so sagen, Wahlbetrug ist so eine Sache, die aus verschiedenen Perspektiven andere Sachen bedeutet. Im aktuellen Wahlkampf ist es ein großes Thema, weil die Republikaner das als Talking Point benutzen in ihrem Wahlkampf und sagen, viele Wahlbetrugsfälle zwingen uns dazu, dass wir die Security hochdrehen. Und das führt dann zu anderen Arten von Wahlbetrug, die werden wir nachher im Einzelnen erklären. Aber dieses Bewusstsein, wir haben hier ein Problem mit dem Wahlbetrug, das ist eine ganz neue Sache. Üblicherweise haben die Amerikaner nie den Eindruck gehabt, dass da groß betrogen wird, so vom Gefühl her.
Da gibt es nochmal mehrere Sachen. Dieses Bewusstsein, es gibt hier Wahlbetrug, ist meistens jetzt ein Republikaner-Trick, um sogenannte Voter-ID-Laws durchzudrücken. Genau, da kommen wir später noch drauf.
Aber so, dass die Bevölkerung an die Politiker herantritt und sagt, wir haben hier Wahlbetrug, wir müssen mal was machen, das gibt es nicht, ne?
Also du meinst, Wahlbetrug im Sinne von Leute gehen doppelt wählen, weil es keine ordentlichen IDs gibt?
Genau, das wäre ja, was ich irgendwie als den offensichtlichen angeworften System gesehen hätte. Und da gibt es wohl auch nicht wirklich eine Verteidigung gegen, weil es nämlich keine Personalsweise gibt. Bei uns ist es ja so, in Deutschland, da kriegt man halt einen Brief, aber im Grunde bist du im System, wenn du geboren bist und dich irgendwo anmeldest, dass du das in deinem Wohnsitz ist, dann kriegst du halt einen Brief, da steht drin, sie können...
Das war ganz automatisch, oder?
Völlig automatisch, man muss da nichts anmelden oder so, sondern du musst halt einfach nur deinen Wohnort im System haben, und das muss man ja eh. Und dann wissen die, wo du wohnst und weisen dir ein Wahllokal zu und da wählst du dann. Und die haben eine Liste, die können sagen, okay, mit dem haben wir gerechnet, der darf hier wählen. Aber das gibt es halt so in den USA nicht, sondern dann gehst du dann in irgendein Wahllokal und es gibt nur das Gegenteil, es gibt eine schwarze Liste sozusagen von Leuten, die nicht wählen dürfen und da kommen wir auch noch zu uns später drauf.
Ja, wie ist das denn eigentlich organisiert, den Wahlland in Amiland? Da mussten wir vielleicht nochmal…
Genau, das sollten wir uns nochmal erklären.
Warum ich jetzt gesagt habe, Washington State liegt daran, dass es in anderen Staaten eben anders aussieht. Das ist noch eine größere, ein unhomogeneres föderales System als in der Bundesrepublik zum Beispiel.
Wäre das nur das einzige Problem, das wäre so gut. Um anzufangen, gibt es sehr viele Arten, Stimmabgabe zu machen. Es gibt dieses traditionelle Voting on Election Day, also dass man zur Wahltag dahin geht und seine Stimme abgibt. Das dauert dann eine Weile, weil da kriegt man so ein Buch, quasi so wie in Hamburg. Du kriegst so ein Buch und du musst auch über 1000 Sachen sich abstimmen. Auch geübte Wähler können da locker mal zehn Minuten mit verbringen.
Weil eben so viele Sachen gebündelt sind in einem Wahl, was wir von dir schon erzählt hatten.
Weil da sehr viele Sachen gebündelt sind in einem Wahl. Dann gibt es die Möglichkeit für Early Voting. Manchmal auch schon zwei Wochen vorher kann man hingehen und wählen.
Im richtigen Wahllokal. Also das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie Briefwahl, sondern man geht hin. Es gibt ein Foto von Obama, der das gemacht hat und es war schon ein richtiges Wahllokal. Das hängt vielleicht auch vom Stand an.
Ja, ja. Dann gibt es Absentee Voting, Vote by Mail.
Also Briefwahl wie bei Anzug.
Briefwahl wie in Deutschland auch. Aber für jede Stadt und auch teilweise für jede County anders organisiert sowieso ist das. Das ganze Wahlprozess wird von den Counties organisiert. Und davon gibt es in jedem Staat hunderte, viele, viele Counties. Teilweise mit Zehntausende Leute drin, teilweise mit Hunderttausende, Millionen Leute drin. Und diese Counties organisieren den Wahl. Und die können alles anders machen. Und du kannst gar nicht glauben, inwiefern das anders sein kann. Das heißt, die können das Ballot-Design selber machen. Die können selber nochmal neue Stellen oder andere Sachen drauf tun. Teilweise, abhängig von was für Minderheiten in so einem County wohnen, gibt es da Ballot-Designs in 20 Sprachen. Du kannst dann teilweise auch Out-of-County-Voting machen, wenn du zur Job gehst oder irgendwo anders bist. Das heißt, dass du dann auch nochmal 20 Ballot-Designs für den County nebenan auch liegen hast. Die dürfen selber bestimmen, wie die Ballot dann aussieht, wie die designt wird. Da kommen wir auch noch drauf, weil da gibt es dann Issues mit. Es ist alles unheimlich kompliziert. Es gibt dann auch noch provisional Ballots. Wenn angezweifelt wird, ob man wählen darf, da kommen wir auch noch ausführlich drauf. Es ist unheimlich kompliziert und eigentlich gibt es dann Fachbegriff, die Amerikaner nennen das ein Complete Fucking Zoo.
Clusterfuck.
Ja, das ist wirklich unglaublich. Ich habe dann ein paar Jahre lang mit diesem Wahlcomputer auch auf Konferenzen rumgehängt, wo dann Leute, die vielleicht nicht so sehr Computergeeks waren, aber die viel mit Wahlen zu tun haben. Und dann aus Amerika gibt es dann solche Geeks, die dann genau wissen, dass es, haja, in dieser County hat es mal dieses Design gegeben. Die haben da solche Computer, die benutzen aber das Software von denen. Und das passt dann zusammen, weil diese Firma, das ist der Ausmaß an Ungleichheit und kompletter Verstreutheit der Technik und der Methoden. Das ist unglaublich.
Dann gibt es ja noch so eine Besonderheit im amerikanischen Wahlsystem, nämlich die sogenannte Lecture College. Das müssen wir glaube ich auch nochmal erklären, weil es gerade für die Wahlen doch relativ von großer Bedeutung ist. Man denkt ja so, naja, wer halt irgendwie Präsident werden will, der muss halt die meisten Stimmen gewinnen.
So ist das nicht, sondern es gibt auch noch so einen Zwischenschritt. Was ja bei uns auch so ist.
Bei uns ist halt der Bundestag. Also bei uns ist halt das Parlament und da gibt es halt dann die Lecture College.
Was ja auch nicht gleich verteilt ist. Also hier kann es halt sein, dass, naja, das gibt ja auch gerade eine verfassungsmäßige Problem mit unserem Wahlrecht, weil das nicht gleich verteilt ist. Also diese Idee, der Wahlmänner hat halt inhärente Probleme. Ist ja auch auf EU-Ebene eine Sache, wo es Beschwerden gibt, dass das nicht gleich verteilt ist, wie viel Stimmgewicht der Einzelne.
Gut, okay, also wir müssen diese Wahlmänner nochmal erklären.
Aber das ist in der Universität eben auch so.
Die Wahlmänner sind halt entstanden historisch, weil dieses Land halt echt doll groß ist. Und sie halt mit Demokratie oder so, was sie mit Demokratie schon angefangen haben, zu Zeiten, wo es nur so richtig zwei, drei Wochen dauern konnte, bis man von einem Ende des Landes abwies nach Washington geschafft hatte. So und...
Kein Telefon, kein Telegraf.
So und die...
Post ging mit dem, wie hieß der Express nochmal?
Die Pferdekutschen.
Ja, wie hieß der?
Pony Express.
Ja, nee, es kam... Western Union, ne?
Ja genau, also Western Union noch eine Post war.
Bevor es eine Bank war.
Ja, bevor es eine Bank wurde. Und deswegen haben die, also wurde die Wahlen so organisiert, dass jeder Staat hat halt seine Wahl durchgeführt und hat dann so genannte Wahlmänner bestimmt. Und diese Wahlmänner sind dann nach Washington gereist und haben den Präsidenten gewählt. Das heißt also, man hat halt den Prozess des Wählens in einem einzelnen Staat von dem Prozess des Wählens des Präsidenten vollständig zeitlich entkoppelt. Und da gibt es halt dann eben diese interessante Besonderheit, dass in den allermeisten Staaten die Wahlmänner nicht proportional vergeben werden. Das heißt also, wenn jetzt halt, nehmen wir mal an, irgendwie in einem Staat, der zwei Wahlmänner und die Hälfte stimmt für den europäische Kandidaten, die Hälfte für den demokratischen Kandidaten. Dann würde man denken, okay, geht halt irgendwie einer, gehen halt zwei Wahlmänner nach Washington, einer stimmt so und einer stimmt so. Aber es ist dann so, dass tatsächlich die noch so knappeste Mehrheit entscheidet darüber, wohin die Stimmen von beiden Wahlmännern aus diesem Staat gehen. Und dadurch sind halt extrem knappe Ausgänge in den einzelnen Staaten relativ wahrscheinlich. Und es führt halt dazu, dass relativ regelmäßig der Präsident nicht gewählt wird, der die meisten Stimmen insgesamt landesweit bekommt, sondern eben natürlich der, der die meisten Wahlmännerstimmen hat, was eben nicht genau dasselbe sein muss.
Insbesondere heißt es auch, dass die meisten Staaten völlig uninteressant sind bei der Wahl, weil man vorher schon weiß, also man weiß jetzt nicht, wie viel die Partei A mehr Stimmen als Partei B haben wird, aber die wählen eigentlich immer Partei A. Und dann weiß man auch, dass alle Wahlmänner rübergehen. Es ist nicht so, dass man sich noch fragt, wie viel Prozent gehen jetzt rüber. Und daher sind die interessanten Staaten bei Präsidentschaftswahlen immer die sogenannten Swing States. Das sind die, wo man es eben nicht weiß und wo sich das noch ändern kann und wo dann gleich mal so was wie sechs oder acht Wahlmänner die Fronten wechseln. Das heißt, das kann richtig Einfluss haben. Und das sind immer so eine Handvoll Staaten, um die es dann geht.
Und da konzentriert sich dann eben doch der Wahlkampf.
Und darauf konzentriert sich der Wahlkampf. Und jetzt gab es hier gerade so eine witzige Geschichte, die ich nochmal kurz erzählen möchte, dass Obama und Romney jetzt so viel Kohle gesammelt haben, dass sie quasi gar nicht mehr wussten, wohin damit. Und dass sie in den Swing States angefangen haben, die Werbung im Fernsehen zu monopolisieren. Da lief dann nichts anderes mehr nachts. Als Wahlwerbung für die beiden Kandidaten immer abwechselt, weil die einfach so viel Kohle da rumliegen hatten. Und Werbung kostet halt nicht viel nachts. Und tagsüber wohl auch. Aber nachts war halt gar nichts anderes mehr. Weil es war so egal. Kaufen wir auch.
Könnt ihr nochmal jemand einschalten.
So läuft das dann.
Also interessant daran ist, dass die, das sollte man nochmal erläutern, dass die Verteilung der Wahlmänner ist, abhängig von der Volkszählung, also davon, wie viele Menschen in den einzelnen Bundesstaaten wohnen. Und dementsprechend ändern sich dann halt auch die Gewichtungen der Wahlmänner. Das heißt, da gibt es ja Staaten, in denen halt mehr Bevölkerung entsteht. Also durch Zuwanderung zum Beispiel oder auch durch höhere Geburtenraten sind dementsprechend dann auch am Ende nach jeweils der Volkszählung alle zehn Jahre kriegen die halt mehr Wahlmänner zugeteilt.
Ich wäre ja auch fast wahlgezählt worden dieses Jahr.
Echt?
War ganz witzig. Naja, ich war gerade auf der Arbeit drüben und die haben mich dann so ein paar Stunden untergebracht. Und da hatte offenbar ein paar Monate vorher noch so ein Inder gewohnt, der in einer indischen Stellung wahrscheinlich da aber wohl eine Green Card hatte. Und der hat sich halt angemeldet und es weggezogen und hat kein Bescheid gesagt. Und dann kam eben diese Wahl-Census-Büro-Tante da statt bei mir in der Tür und wollte mich unbedingt zählen und mich interviewen. Ich sage jetzt nein oder nicht. War ganz witzig. Aber jetzt hat sie doch was tun können. Ja, aber diesen Fall gab es halt nicht in deren Bürokratur sozusagen. Nee, den gibt es hier nicht mehr.
Registriert aber weggezogen?
Ja, so das gab es halt nicht. Ich habe eine halbe Stunde mit der verhandelten und gesagt, wissen Sie, tun wir doch einfach so, als sei ich nicht da gewesen. Und das ging dann.
Okay, war lieber da. Interessanter an ist, dass diese offizielle Begründung, also sozusagen die Wikipedia-Begründung, warum es halt irgendwie dieses Wahlmänner-System gibt, also mit den großen Entfernungen und so, dass es natürlich nur die halbe Wahrheit ist. Also es gibt halt relativ gut dokumentiert die Pöbel-Furcht der Gründungsväter der amerikanischen Demokratie. Die halt nicht so richtig glaubten, dass halt eine reine Mehrheitswahl, wo halt irgendwie die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung entscheidet, nun das Richtige sei, sondern lieber wollten, dass dann nochmal so ein Schritt von weißen Männern, die dann im Zweifel halt noch irgendwie den Irrtum der Bevölkerung korrigieren können dazwischen ist.
The people are uninformed and would be misled by a few designing men, sagten dann so, so Abgeordneten.
Ich finde das sehr spannend, weil es genau eine Kontinuität bis heute gibt. Es gibt zwar Unterschiede in dem Ausmaß, also die Umstände waren ja damals so, dass Frauen und Schwarze nicht wählen durften und das waren ja Sklaventreiber, von denen wir hier reden, die Wahlberechtigten. Und die haben sich aber trotzdem vor Pöbelsorgen gemacht und meinten damit aber nicht die Frauen und Schwarzen, die ihn nicht wählen konnten, sondern so in ihrer kleinen Elite, die unten. Und heute haben wir im Grunde dieselben Argumente, aber bezogen auf andere. Also der Anteil derer, die Teil von der wählen dürfen, in der Elite sind, ist größer geworden. Aber die Argumente sind im Grunde genau dieselben. Ja, das gibt es ja hier genauso, diese Idee, dass wenn man die Leute nur tatsächlich abstimmen ließe, dann käme lauter populärer Unsinn raus. Und heute wird gerne als Argument genommen, dass wir sowas wie die Bildzeitung haben, die dann eben bei uns die öffentliche Meinung beeinflussen könnte. Das gab es ja damals noch gar nicht. Da gab es zwar auch Medien, aber die waren keineswegs aktuell und auch nicht so verbreitet, also mit so viel Einfluss auf das Leben wie heute, aber trotzdem dieselben Argumente gekommen. Und da stellt sich für mich natürlich die Frage, ob das nicht vorgeschoben ist, die Sache mit den Medien heute, ob das nicht nun eine Entschuldigung dafür ist, dass wir im Grunde dieselbe Vorricht immer noch haben, die die damals hatten.
Es gibt ja durchaus Bestrebungen, dieses Winner-Tax-It-All-System in einigen Staaten abzuschaffen.
Ja, es gibt mehrere Staaten, ich glaube jetzt zwei oder drei, die verteilen die Stimmen proportional. Was natürlich heißt, dass sie für Wahlkampf nicht mehr interessant sind. Da kommt kein Campaign mehr vorbei. Weil, ob man dann da denn drei oder vier der neuen Sitze oder vier oder fünf der neuen Sitze bekommt, ist dann egal.
Das heißt, die Fernsehsender sind dann wahrscheinlich dagegen, dass Staaten solche Systeme adoptieren, weil sie dann die Wahlkampf-Spot-Einnahmen nicht haben?
Oder so, ich weiß nicht.
Nein, Moment, Moment, es geht ja nicht zu den Fernsehsendern, sondern es geht an die Kabelbetreiber.
Ah, okay, naja.
Also das ist nochmal, dann können wir eine eigene Sendung zu machen, wie das TV-System in den USA funktioniert. Das ist auch richtig pervers.
Okay, aber weiter.
Nochmal zu Electoral College und dieses Mehrheit der Stimmen versus Mehrheit dieser Wahlmänner. Ist tatsächlich nur noch dreimal in der Geschichte vorgekommen, dass derjenige, der die Mehrheit an Stimmen hat, Er dachte, wir öfter, okay. Nee, war es nur dreimal vorgekommen, in 1876, in 1888 und dann neulich in 2000, als George Bush The Popular Vote verloren hat, als er so ein weniger Stimmen bekommen hat, aber trotzdem von Ergore gewonnen hat. Da gab es diese Florida Geschichte, da kommen wir noch drauf.
Wo der Supreme Court gewonnen hat.
Und? Und? Wenn der Wahl ausgeht, so wie die Umfragen von gestern aussehen, dann wird Romney der Popular Vote gewinnen und Obama trotzdem die meisten Wahlmänner haben.
Ach, okay.
Also könnte die vierte Mal sein, dass es passiert.
Okay, aber es gab doch auch noch diese Initiative, wo Staaten gesagt haben, dass sie sich zusammentun und die Wahlmänner nach dem Popular Vote zusammensetzen.
Erstmal, dieses ganze System nervt die 80 Prozent der Bevölkerung ungefähr in Amerika, die nicht in Battleground oder Swing States wohnt. Also die nicht in so einem Staat wohnen, wo es die eine oder andere Richtung gehen kann. Dessen Bevölkerung nervt das komplett, weil der ganze Wahlkampf geht nicht um ihren Themen, geht nicht um ihren Begehren. Da rennen sich diese Politiker, irgendwelche Leute in Ohio und Florida hinterher und die Leute in New York, Los Angeles, San Francisco. Die 80 Prozent der US-Bevölkerung nervt dieses System komplett.
Also ich möchte aber noch mal darauf hinweisen, dass selbst wenn du die Wahlmänner anders verteilst, hast du immer noch Rundungsfehler. Wenn jetzt irgendwie drei Prozent...
Aber gut, aber...
Nee, aber ich meine, es ist immer scheiße, wenn du die Wahlleute hast. Wir können es jetzt ein bisschen weniger scheiße machen, aber es ist immer gut.
Aber es ist nicht nur die Wahlmänner, sondern auch Winner takes all. Auch wenn es die Wahlmänner nicht gäbe, sondern Winner takes all. Es ist halt so, dass die Bevölkerung von New York oder San Francisco, es ist eigentlich egal, ob die zur Wahl gehen. Kann man natürlich nicht so sagen, aber es ist eigentlich egal, weil die, weil die Staaten, Kalifornien und New York, gehen zu den Demokraten. Immer schon wird noch eine Weile so bleiben, da wohnen junge Leute, die sind gut ausgebildet, die gehen zur Uni, die wählen Demokraten und das wird so bleiben. Sprich, es ist für 80 Prozent der Leute in Amerika, es hat dann auch so eine Sinnlosigkeit, sich mit diesem Prozess zu befassen. Also viele Leute wollen gerade auch nach dieser Nummer mit George W. Bush in 2000, ziemlich viele Leute wollen dieses Electoral College loswerden. Aber da steht ein Grundgesetz, die Constitution, das braucht zwei Drittel im Haus und im Senat noch mal drei Viertel und dann muss es von den States zertifiziert werden.
Das klingt nicht so wahrscheinlich.
Wird es nicht so wahrscheinlich. Dafür gibt es jetzt einen Trick. Da gab es auch schon mehrere Iterations von diesem Trick, aber das heißt den National Popular Vote Plan, auch wohl National Popular Vote Interstate Compact genannt. Und es geht davon aus, dass sich Staaten zusammentun, die versprechen, sobald wir in diesem Compact die Mehrheit der Wahlmänner haben, irgendwann, sobald so viele Staaten dieses Compact unterschrieben haben, dass wir zusammen mehr als 270 Wahlmänner haben, dann vergeben wir alle unsere Wahlmänner an derjenige, der der Popular Vote über die ganzen Vereinigten Staaten gewonnen hat.
Naja, das ist nicht überzeugend.
Das gibt dann aber auch interessante Effekte.
Das heißt also, sobald die Mehrheit der Staaten dieses unterschreibt, dann können wir mit einer einfachen Mehrheit von Staaten, können wir die Popular Vote, die Präsident wählen lassen. Und dann können wir dieses ganze System ignorieren, dann ist es egal. Weil die Staaten dürfen nämlich selber bestimmen, das muss man dann verstehen. Die Staaten dürfen selber das Mechanismus bestimmen, wodurch die diese Wahlmänner vergeben.
Das heißt, die können auch gegen das stimmen, was eigentlich rausgekommen ist oder wie?
Die Frage, ob das Supreme Court das akzeptiert, weil da gibt es auch das Voting Rights Act und da gibt es noch eine Menge so Gesetze.
Aber es gibt das Trauma wieder, dass so vereinzelte Wahlmänner sagen, sie stimmen für was anderes.
Naja, sogenannte unfaithful electors gibt es. Es hat einmal einen Fehler gegeben. Da gab es in dem Wahlwoch John Kerry versus Bush, George W und da gab es dann einen, der hat zweimal für John Edwards gestimmt. Da hat John Edwards, der Visepräsident Kandidaten, also eine Stimme für Präsidenten bekommen. Der ist dann zweimal gewählt worden von diesem unfaithful elector. Aber im Prinzip wählen die schon das, was die gesagt haben. Aber müssen sie nicht.
Das heißt also, dieses Interstate Compact könnte zumindest im Prinzip funktionieren?
Dieses Interstate Compact könnte funktionieren. Und jetzt haben die schon 132 Stimmen. Die sind also quasi, die brauchen noch 138. Die sind quasi auf der Hälfte, um diesen Compact komplett zu machen. Und die sind nur vier, fünf Jahre dabei. Also muss man noch nicht ganz abstreiten.
Du hast Hoffnung.
Naja, du musst es nicht ganz ignorieren, dass es möglich ist, dass wir in fünf oder zehn Jahre dieses ganze System nicht mehr haben. Und dass es dann plötzlich von ein auf den anderen Tag durch diesen Magic Trick, proportional, landesbreite Proportionalwahl ist, mit nicht mehr Winner takes all nirgendwo. Und dass plötzlich alle Stimmen wieder gleichwert sind. Und dass es nicht diese Riesenkonzentration auf Ohio und Florida und, dass das vom einen auf dem anderen Jahr innerhalb fünf oder zehn Jahre plötzlich verschwunden sein kann. Muss man einfach nicht als Möglichkeit abschreiben, dass das sich noch mal ganz ändert.
Wir haben jetzt einen Punkt übersprungen, nämlich das Gerrymandering. Und das finde ich passt gut in den Kontext von, dass diese Wahlen für einen Großteil der Bevölkerung sinnlos sind. Denn das ist nicht nur auf Landesebene so, sondern ist auch auf Wahlkreisebene so.
Aber Wahlkreisen sind für Präsidentwahlen nicht so wichtig, weil das ist Winner takes all über den ganzen Staat.
Naja, aber ich meine, die Frage ist, gehst du überhaupt zur Wahl hin? Oder spielt das eh keine Rolle? Also auch bei anderen Wahlentscheidungen als der Präsidentschaftswahl gibt es diesen Effekt, dass du im Grunde...
Gut, dann erklären wir Gerrymandering.
Das fing, glaube ich, gar nicht an als Wahlbetrug, sondern das ist erst später. Am Anfang war das irgendwie, wir machen jetzt mal effizientere Wahlkreisverteilung.
Lass uns den Hörer einfach mal kurz erklären, für wer es nicht weiß, was Gerrymandering ist. Gerrymandering ist das Neu-Einteilen der Wahlbezirke. Neue Grenzen ziehen auf der Karte für Wahlbezirke.
Moment, das wird eh nach jedem Zensus gemacht.
Ja, in Amerika passiert das nach jedem Zensus. Also alle zehn Jahre werden Wahlbezirke neu gemacht, weil sich dann die Anzahl Abgeordneten in einem Staat ändern kann. Und da braucht man halt neue Grenzen. Die Frage ist dann, wo liegen wir die Grenzen? Wie verteilt man die?
Da gibt es eben diesen Entwurf, diese Idee, dass man die so verteilt, dass das Ergebnis im Grunde schon feststeht. Also man macht seine Bezirke so, dass in diesem Bezirk sind eigentlich nur Leute, die E-Demokraten wählen. Und in jedem Bezirk, da sind die ganzen Leute, die E-Republikaner wählen. Und da hat man dann mehr halten so 80, 90 Prozent wie damals im Osten. Und das machen tatsächlich auch beide Parteien mit. Also das ist nicht nur eine Sache, die die fiese Republikanerpartei macht, sondern das machen auch die Demokraten, die sich halt denken, dass sie so ihre Hochburgen sichern können.
Das geht um mehrere Sachen. Es geht um Hochburgen sichern.
Es geht um diese incumbent Sache.
Genau, es geht darum, dass sie sozusagen Verlässigkeit und Machterhalt haben und darum, dass sie halt nicht zu viele Counties haben, wo sie halt relativ viel Wahlkampfkohle reinbuttern müssen, weil die halt umstritten sind. Was dabei rauskommt, sind dann halt so Wahlbezirke, die völlig bizarr geformt sind. Also die halt nicht...
Unzusammenhängende Wahlbezirke gibt es da teilweise. Also hier ein Fleckchen, da ein Fleckchen. Damit es nicht so schlimm aussieht, haben wir diese Autobahn, die in der Mitte durchgeht. Die machen wir jetzt auch Teil zum Wahlbezirk. Dann gibt es wenigstens einen Übergang. Also es ist unglaublich. Jaja. Und das ist natürlich auch eine Art von Wahlbetrug. Na klar.
Interessanterweise findet sowas in Deutschland ja auch statt, ne?
Ja.
Also das halt die... Vielleicht sollte noch mal eine Sendung zur Bundestagswahl machen. Fällt mir ein.
Sollten wir auf jeden Fall tun.
Also wo wir...
Wahlen-Nerds einladen.
Wo wir das noch mal ein bisschen betrachten. Aber genau diese Frage, wie gestalten man Wahlbezirke? Und verschiebt man halt eben Mehrheiten dadurch, dass man mehr von seinen eigenen Anhängern damit reinschiebt. Zum Beispiel in Berlin war das ja so, hier mit der Restrukturierung der Wahlbezirke, dass plötzlich die SPD hier, ich glaube, ein paar Stimmen Mehrheit in einigen Wahlbezirken hat und dadurch Kandidaten durchbekommen hat, die sie vorher nicht durchbekommen hätte. Man sieht eben, der Teufel steckt da eben im Detail bei der Demokratie. Ja, was passiert dann eigentlich, wenn jetzt dieses Election College einen Padd hat?
Das kann passieren, weil es ist eine gerade Anzahl. Es könnte genau 269 Stimmen eine Seite, 269 Stimmen auf der anderen Kandidaten stimmen.
Super, gerade Anzahl. What could possibly go wrong?
Wenn das passiert...
Dann holt man Würfel.
Das geht bei bestimmte Kombinationen von Battlegrounds States, die in eine oder andere Richtung fallen. Es geht auch, wenn irgendein Elektor mal Bock hat auf Humor und in die andere Richtung wählt. Dann bestimmen die beiden Kammer des Parlaments. Das Haus bestimmt dann der Präsident. Und wenn das Haus durchgehend von Republikanern dominiert wird...
Wie im Moment?
Wie im Moment, dann wird der Präsident Romney. Und der Senat bestimmt dann der Vizepräsident. Die sind momentan von Demokraten beherrscht. Und das wäre dann Biden. Dann haben wir also ein Romney-Biden-Whitehouse.
Großartig.
Das wäre interessant. Auf jeden Fall. Ist noch nie vorgekommen. Aber wäre interessant.
Weil die Chancen stehen dieses Mal nicht so gut, oder?
Nee. Na ja, auf jeden Fall wird es knapp.
Ja gut, aber dadurch, dass es der ganze Staat umkippt in diesem Wahlsystem, gibt es eigentlich...
Ist die Chance immer noch nicht groß, dass es genau 269 wird. Aber es gibt wiederum solche Election-Herds, die haben schon ein paar Szenarien ausgedacht, wo es ging.
Aber ich meine, das ist ja generell eher witzig, wenn man sich diese Notfall-Succession auf, was weiß ich, beim Militär oder beim Kabinett anguckt. Wer dann unter welchen Bedingungen beim Atomschlag die Macht übernimmt. Das ist nie richtig toll. Am Ende regiert er wie der Hausmeister, weil die anderen alle tot sind.
Bei uns regiert er am Ende das Verfassungsgericht. Das geht schon noch. Tatsächlich.
Super.
Es gibt ja so ein Szenario von irgendwie Ausfällen, wo am Ende tatsächlich das Verfassungsgericht regiert.
Machen sie ja in gewisser Sicht heute schon.
Ja, also ich weiß, es wäre wahrscheinlich nicht das schlechteste Notfall. Na gut. Ja, dann sollten wir vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen darüber reden, wie denn so die in Amieland technisch gewählt wird, also wie die Technik aussieht, was natürlich für die Nerds unter unseren Hörern durchaus der interessante Teil ist.
Ja, da muss man wiederum sagen, das passt genau. Die Technik ist genauso strukturiert wie das System auch, a complete fucking zoo.
Okay, gar nicht.
Naja.
Die rufen sich dann halt an und sagen, also wir haben 18 Stimmen gezählt.
Ja, naja, wie gesagt, alle Counties dürfen das anders machen, machen das auch anders in der Praxis. Und es gibt schon lange Technik-Einsatz. Schon lange bevor es Computer gab, gab es Technik-Einsatz. Es gab sogenannte Punch-Ballads. Da gab es in Florida noch welche davon. Lochkarten. Mit diesen Lochkarten, mit diesen Hanging Chads, wo man dann also ein Stück Papier perforiert hat, mit einem speziellen Zanger oder spezielles Gerät Löcher reingemacht hat, damit sie automatisiert gezählt werden können. Es gab Lever-Machines in New York bis vor ganz kurzem.
Das muss man sich vorstellen wie so eine Slot-Maschine, wo man dann rechst einen Hebel hat und kutsch macht.
Es ist ein bisschen vorstellbar, als so eine Maschine zwei Meter hoch, eine Meter breit mit einem Vorhang davor. Da macht man so mit einem Hebel den Vorhang zu. Da macht es auch groß klack, klack, klack, klack, klack. Und dann macht man mit kleinen Hebelchen, selektiert man die Kandidaten und Races und Ballett-Initiatives und alles. Und dann macht man einmal klack, dann geht der Vorhang wieder auf und dann zählt auf kleinen Zähler. So wie, kennst du die alte Telefontechnik, wo es dann diese kleine Mechanikzähler gab? Die waren dann natürlich noch nicht mit Elektromagneten, sondern so kleine Mechanikzähler haben dann weitergezählt. Da gab es auch tausend Tricks, um die zu manipulieren, mit kleinen Holzstücken, die man dann am Ende des Wahltags einfach rausgenommen hat, durch einmal eine Wähler reinzuschicken, die dann richtig, richtig viel Kraft, viel Kraft, Gatschunk gemacht hat. Da gab es auch tausend Tricks. Aber so Mechanikgeräte gab es schon echt lange, schon lange bevor Computern. Dann kam Wahlcomputer, auch schon vor 2000 in den 90ern, eigentlich genauso wie bei uns in Holland zumindest, gab es da computerisierte Wahl und die sind da eigentlich grob über die letzten 20 Jahre in zwei Richtungen gegangen. Es gibt da die eine Richtung, sind so die DREs, Direct Recording Electronic Machines. Da sind die Wahlcomputer, die eigentlich nur im Computerspeicher, die schwarzen Kisten, die Black Box Voting, die nur im Computerspeicher irgendwie behalten, wie viele Stimmen eine Kandidat hat, so wie unsere alten NADAPs.
Genau, so wie die NADAPs, die auch in Deutschland am Einsatz waren und dieses Verfassungsgericht dann verboten hat.
Genau, Black Box Voting Machines, die gibt es dann mittlerweile auch ausgerüstet mit sogenannten VV-Pads, Voter Verified Paper Audit Trail, wobei man dann nochmal einen Ausdruck hat, was man gewählt hat und die dann nochmal separat in eine Tonne schmeißt, damit, wenn mal Zweifel ist, nachgezählt werden kann. Das ist dann auch doof, weil wann ist denn Zweifel?
Diese DIY-Machines, also die halt nur in den Speicherrekorden, also wenn man so die Bilder sich hinschaut aus Amiland, dann sind es ja weniger so NEDAP-Style-Maschinen mitzuknöpfen, sondern meistens eher so Touchscreen-Dinger, also so.
Ja, es gibt sie beide. Es gibt auch noch von Sequoia Voting Systems, gibt es die AVC-Machines und das sind wirklich NEDAPs. Also im gleichen Zeitalter mit dem gleichen 68.000 Prozessoren.
Haben sie die lizenziert oder wie?
Riesen-Mainboards, ne, sind eigene Riesen-Mainboards.
Aber es hat den selben Stil.
Und die sind von Andrew Apple in New Jersey. Professor Apple, sind die genauso gehackt worden, wie wir hier bei den NEDAPs gemacht haben. Also es gibt ein wissenschaftliches Feld, was sich mit Sicherheit in so Voting-Technik und Voting-Computern beschäftigt. Und das ist einer der langweiligste wissenschaftliche Felder überhaupt in der Welt. Weil alle Paper sehen gleich aus. Wir fassen das an, ach, hier ist das kaputt. Und dann schreiben wir mal die übelsten zehn Sachen über dieses Gerät auf und passen dabei gut auf, nicht irgendwie zu suggesten, dass wenn man diese zehn Löcher fixt, dass das dann sicher ist, weil es sicher geht überhaupt nicht. Das erklärt man dann in jedes Paper nochmal in drei Seiten, dass diese Technik nicht sicher geht.
Und es wird aber von den Leuten, die die Dinge bauen und kaufen, ignoriert?
Es wird komplett ignoriert, weil die Kunden sind ja Gemeinden und Counties und irgendwelche Behörden, die eigentlich...
Die sind halt doof.
Naja...
Die haben eigene Motivationen.
Naja, die Wahlbehörden in der Welt haben mit Wahlen eine Menge Stress. Mit Papierwahl mehr Stress als mit Computern, weil ist das jetzt ein Kreuzchen oder nicht oder sind das jetzt zwei Kreuzchen oder ist das nicht gemeint? Oder die haben da eine Menge Zweifel, eine Menge Stress und müssen nachzählen. Und mit diesem Computer kommt eine Firma hin. Die stellen da Technik her. Da gibt es auch noch tausend Probleme und das ist alles nicht so einfach, wie ich es jetzt sage und teilweise haben die auch echt bereut, dass die diese Technik gekauft haben. Aber zumindest in der Theorie...
In den Broschüren.
Naja, auch.
Und sowohl in Holland und Deutschland, auch in der Praxis muss man halt nicht sagen. Man stellt so eine Kiste hin. Man versteht zwar nicht, was in diese Kiste passiert, was natürlich ein Problem ist, rein im Kopf so. Aber für diese Leute hat das eine Menge Probleme gelöst.
Es kommt ein Ergebnis raus.
Kommt eine Firma und am Ende des Tages...
Und sagt dir jetzt 42...
Alle Wähler drücken einen Knopf und am Ende des Tages kommt ein Bong raus und das total stimmt. Das ist bei Papierwahl auch noch nicht mal gesagt. Das ist immer... Gibt es da tausend Fehler? Das total stimmt und alles ist prima.
Obwohl bei unseren Wahlbeobachtungen stimmt nie totals häufiger auch mal nicht, wenn wir die Lappmaschinen angeguckt haben.
Aber zumindest alles, was da rauskommt in Holland, hat halbwegs gestimmt und am Ende hat man keinen Stress. Ich war in India und da haben wir auch geredet mit so Leute aus der Wahlbürokratie, aus der Election Commission of India selber. Und die haben dann gesagt, ja hören sie mal, alles schön und gut, dass wir nicht vertrauen können, was in diese Computer abgeht und dass es manipuliert werden kann. Aber es gibt hier Bezerke und Länder, wo, wenn es am Wahlabend weniger als 200 Leute sterben, dann hatten wir einen guten Wahl. Und wenn es da weniger Konflikte gibt.
Eine andere Perspektive des Problems.
Also ich bin da vorsichtig, die Leute, die die Wahl organisieren, zu sehr dumm, doof, von Betrug motiviert. Die haben ein Problem, die wollen das gelöst haben. Und Game Theory, Game theoretisch, er spielt theoretisch, will man sein Problem gerne irgendwo anders hinschieben. Und die haben das Problem einfach dahin geschoben, dass es, wir verstehen zwar nicht mehr, was abgeht, aber das heißt auch, wir haben das Problem nicht mehr. Und natürlich will man das als Bevölkerung, die größere Interesse ist ja die Bevölkerung und dass wir noch eine Demokratie haben. Als Bevölkerung will man das nicht, muss man das verhindern. Aber so direkt, nee, nehme ich das nicht ab. Aber es gibt halt eine Menge Technik in den Vereinigten Staaten und auch hier.
Man hat ja versucht zu sagen, wenn es jetzt Misstrauen gegen diese Recordingsysteme gibt, wo also alles im Speicher des Computers stattfindet, dann lösen wir das Problem noch dadurch, indem wir da noch einen Drucker ranhängen und jeder Wähler halt noch einen Ausdruck dessen bekommt, was der Computer glaubt, dass er gewählt hat.
Ja, das wollen jetzt alle. Eigentlich alle Länder, die jetzt noch was einführen wollen, die wollen das mit Papertrail, mit diesem VV-Pad, mit Photoverified Paper Audit Trail. In Holland gibt es dafür wieder Stimmen.
Also man muss nur mal...
Na, weil das auch in den Papers drin stand. Da stand drin, wie, es gibt nicht mal einen Audit Trail. Und jetzt sagen die halt, naja, gut, dann machen wir halt einen Audit Trail.
Nein, nein, der interessante Punkt daran ist ja, dass ja dieser Audit Trail ja durchaus Augenwischerei ist. Also zum einen, also wir hatten eine Diskussion ja auch in Hamburg, als wir da, wenn die im Wahlstift waren, da ging es ja genau ums selbe. Also wenn du hast halt zwei, quasi zwei Wahlergebnisse, du hast eins auf Papier, du hast eins elektronisch. Und wenn jetzt eine Intervagenz dazwischen feststellst, was tust du dann? Also welches Ergebnis zählt? Zählt das Papier oder zählt das elektronische Ergebnis oder wählst du nochmal oder was tust du dann eigentlich?
Ja das ist einer der große Probleme. Was tust du, wenn es nicht stimmt? Weil da musste eigentlich, das kann eigentlich nur heißen, dass da Softwareprobleme gibt. Und wenn das so ist, dann musst du eigentlich alles zählen. Aber die Leute sind schon nach Hause. Weil das war der ganze Punkt, dass die Leute nach Hause können. Also das ist ein Problem. Das andere Problem ist, man muss statistisch genug nachzählen, dass man auch weiß, dass man Betrug irgendwie erfassen kann.
Also nicht nur eine kleine Stichprobe, sondern halt eben auch schon relativ viel Stichprobe.
Oder sogar sagen, wir zählen nur nach, wenn es Zweifel gibt. Weil Zweifel gibt es in unserem Wahlsystem, wobei es immer knapper wird.
Also zum Beispiel, in Venezuela zum Beispiel haben sie es ja so gemacht, da war jetzt gerade eine der größten Wahlcomputerwahlen überhaupt, mit Paper-Ordertrails. Wo? Und da haben sie ein Drittel nachgezählt. Und zwar auf Empfehlung von der Carta-Stiftung, glaube ich.
Und?
Na, sie haben quasi keine Diskrepanzen gefunden. Also die haben halt versucht, es so beide book zu machen, wie es irgendwie geht. Also irgendwie mit fünf Parteien, die die Software geordert haben. Nur ein Wahlcomputer Nationwide. Also ein Typ-Paper-Trail und irgendwie große Stichproben und irgendwie Wähler-Identifikation mit Fingerprint und Die. Also dass sie halt den Finger einfärben und so.
Das ist aber nicht die gleiche Maschine.
Du hast ja auch keine Vorteile mehr von dem Wahlcomputer, wenn du so viel Aufwand treibst.
Na ja doch, du hast halt schnell ein Ergebnis und du kannst halt kein Ballett-Stuffing machen.
Aber wenn der Wahlcomputer weiß, wer der Wähler ist.
Das haben sie getrennt. Naja, das sagen sie, dass sie das getrennt haben.
Soweit ich die Maschine verstehe und soweit ich die Wahl da verstehe, ist das getrennt in Software.
Na ja klar, es ist eine sichere Software-Trennung.
Eine sichere Software-Trennung, das heißt, man braucht nur der Gerücht, dass es diese Trennung nicht gibt, um die Wahl zu beeinflussen.
Es hat auch niemand geglaubt, wenn er zu illa ist, dass es getrennt ist.
Du brauchst die Technik nicht zu manipulieren. Du brauchst nur das, was die Leute über diese Technik glauben, zu manipulieren, um in den Wahl einzugreifen.
Sie dachten, Chavez weiß, wenn sie nicht für ihn gestimmt haben, dann brauchst du halt doppelt so viel Vermut dafür.
Aber es gibt in Amieland noch ein System, worüber wir auch mal reden sollen. Das ist diese Pre-Synced-Obscan.
Ich will noch kurz die Probleme mit dem Peppa-Trail zu Ende machen, weil da gibt es noch ein paar lustige. Zum einen eines der Dinge, die in den USA jampten, da halt die Drucker, dann konnten sie nicht weiterwählen. Das war halt auch so ein Klassiker.
Vor allem, die haben das ja getestet vorher. Aber sie haben es halt in ihrem Büro mit Klimaanlage getestet und das Wahllokal ist dann in Georgia auf der Straße. Da ist feucht und heiß und dann wird das Papier quillt auf und dann jampt es halt.
Es gibt sehr viele Störungen in Wahlsystemen in Amerika, die mit Klima zu tun haben. Auch die Hanging Chats sind mehr aufgetreten da, wo das Papier feucht war.
Weil das Papier dann weich ist.
Weil das Papier dann weich ist. Auch diese ganzen Calibration-Probleme mit Touchscreens treten auch mehr auf, wenn es warm ist. Die Lamination, wenn es feucht ist. Also die ganzen Probleme, die mit warm und feucht zu tun haben, haben auch einen Bias. Die treten nämlich da auf, wo die armere Bevölkerung stimmt.
Wo es halt keine Klimaanlagen in Wahlkabinen gibt.
Die Reichen stimmen nämlich in irgendwelche Reichenschulen, wo es Klimaanlagen gibt. Die Armen stimmen in irgendeinen Sportsaal irgendwo, wo es keine Klimaanlagen gibt. Also das kann man auch ausnutzen. Zumindest als Faktor benutzen dadurch, dass man da nichts dagegen macht. Auch wenn man es nicht schon vorne rein geplant hat, kann man es ausnutzen dadurch, dass man es nicht irgendwie fixt.
Mein Lieblingsproblem mit diesen Paper-Trails war, ich habe vergessen, wo es war, da haben sie mit so einem Thermo-Drucker den Paper-Trail gemacht, also so Kassenbond-Drucker, und die Ohne stand auf der Heizung, und dann war die unterste Drittel von Zettel in der Ohne einfach unlesbar, weil der Thermo-Streifen durch die Heizung war gemacht wurde.
Die besten der besten.
Ja, also wie gesagt, Paper-Trail.
Na gut, aber es gibt ja noch andere Sachen. Ich muss mal hier ins Call-Zelt schon wieder dran vorbei. Das ist ja auch, es stellt sich ja die Frage, was ist denn, wenn ich jetzt wähle und ich stelle fest, auf dem Zettel steht CDU, aber ich habe eigentlich SPD gewählt. Was mache ich denn dann? Muss ich dann in so einem Arbitration-Blah mich mit irgendwelchen Beamten unterhalten, verliere ich dann noch eine Stunde? Wir haben ja gesagt, das ist in Amerika wochentags und das ist Zeit, für die ich nicht bezahlt werde und davor und danach will ich eigentlich wieder arbeiten gehen. Das heißt, wenn der Aufwand, den ich auf mich nehmen muss, wenn meine Stimme nicht stimmt, wenn der Dignifikant...
Stell dir mal vor, du bist in Amerika und nur die Bestätigung, was du da gerade gewählt hast, passt nicht auf einem Bildschirm, weil du hast in tausend Sachen gewählt.
Ja, das kommt auch dazu, aber du kriegst ja ein Stück Papier, ich meine jetzt Paper Trail. Aber der Punkt ist, nehmen wir mal an, da ist jetzt eine Diskrepanz und wenn ich damit rechnen muss, dass das jetzt eine Stunde dauert, die ich dann auch in irgendeinem Wahlbüro rumhängen muss und mit irgendwelchen Leuten reden muss, um das zu klären, dann kann es den Punkt überschreiten, den ich da investieren kann in die Wahl. Das heißt, das ist wieder eine Sache, die, obwohl sie möglicherweise nicht so gemeint ist, aber doch zu Lasten gewisser Bevölkerungsschichten geht.
Es gibt mit diesen Diaries, da hat es auch echte Probleme gegeben überall. Es gab zum Beispiel ESNS, die Firma Election Systems & Software, die hatten in 2006, da gab es so eine Zwischenzeitwahl, das war keine Präsidentwahl, da gab es in Florida, in Sarasota County, da gab es 18.000 und Untervotes, Undervotes.
Also Leute hatten abgestimmt, aber das war dann nicht gezählt worden.
Die haben abgestimmt für allerhand andere Sachen, aber nicht für Member of the House, also nicht für die wichtige Wahl, was sehr unwahrscheinlich ist, weil das war erwartet, dass das ein paar Hundert waren, es waren 18.000 und das war in den anderen Counties, war das auch gar nicht so. Also da ist was schiefgegangen, niemand weiß ganz genau was, aber das hat dann der Wahl gekippt und man kann es nicht mehr nachgucken, weil es ja alles Blackbox-Voting, ja, der Software hat irgendwas gemacht, wir wissen nicht was. Und diese gleiche Firma ISNS war hier in Deutschland schon komplett fertig mit einer Wahlmaschine mit großen Bürschel, um auf der deutsche Markt zu kommen, als wir dann diese, diese......nied abzulegen kamen. Ja, nied abzulegen haben und das hier dann über Bundesverfassungsgericht mit die Klage von Ulrich Wiesner dann alles geendet ist.
Naja, die, die war noch diese IOS- und S-Maschinen. Ich weiß nicht, da haben wir uns drauf gefreut, dass wir dann endlich mal richtig Tempestangriff machen können, weil die so eine Monster-Touch-Screens hatten.
Jaja, das war....
War das nicht windows-basiert sogar, was sie hatten?
Kann sein, ja.
Also ich erinnere mich da an ganz furchtbare Sachen. Also es gab auch Fälle, wo ein Stromausfall war. Also es gab da auch Fälle, wo es ein Stromausfall, oder wo es einen Kurzschluss in den Wahlcomputern gab, weil es halt zu feucht war in der Luft und so. Und dann weiß man bei diesen DRI-Maschinen eben auch nicht, hatte das jetzt noch ein Flash geschrieben, oder ist das jetzt weg, oder fehlt die Hälfte. Also das ist alles Probleme, die man nicht haben will, natürlich nicht.
Wir hatten in Holland eine Wahlcomputer, war von SDU, unserer selbstständig alte Staatsdruckerei. Und das war eine Windows-Kiste mit drahtlos Modem drin, die das denn benutzt haben, um das Wahlergebnis am Ende des Tages per GSM ein Upload zu machen. Und da war alles geregelt, was da war geregelt, dass es so viel Wasser abkönnen muss, es darf wieder Stecker aussehen sollte. Alles war geregelt, aber ja, das war ein Windows und das war ein Weihlos Modem. Und da war nichts drüber geregelt, ob das jetzt sicher sein muss oder ob das überhaupt...
Haben sie SSL benutzt wenigstens?
Naja, das war noch...
Auch GSL müsste doch sicher...
Und die waren es auch, bei denen die Tempest-Abstrahlung irgendwie richtig doll war, ne?
Die haben das benutzt, um die Maschinen denn loszuwerden, bevor der Wahl. Unser Gesetz war ja, dass man damit wählen dürfte. Und das wollten die dann nicht mehr, weil die dann...
Das war doch sogar noch so, dass euer Verfassungsschutz die getestet hat, ne? Euer AWD war das doch, ne? Wie war das in dem Report, dass die Abstrahlung so groß war, dass sie nicht mehr auf ihrem Gelände testen konnten? Wie weit sie reichen? Sowas statt doch da drin. Naja, die besten der besten.
Also die Antwort auf diese ganzen Systeme ist, das heißt normalerweise, dass man ein Optikel-Scan benutzt, aber das halt hat auch seine eigenen Probleme. Das muss man sich so vorstellen, dass man einen normalen Papierzettel kriegt zum Abstimmen und den legt man dann eben auf diesen Scanner drauf und der liest das eben ab. Und das klingt gut.
Es ist vergleichbar mit, so wie man hier zum Beispiel in der Uni seine Multiple-Choice-Tests macht. So Geräte, die dann scannen und die die Antworten dann lesen und Scoring machen, das macht man dann halt für den Wahrheit auch.
Das heißt, die Wahlzeiten sind darauf optimiert, dass sie gut zu scannen sind.
Ja, da gibt es so entweder so kleine Ausmalboxen, die feed man rein und dann kommt es entweder zurück, wenn man zum Beispiel zwei Kandidaten in einem Race gewählt hat, dann sagt der Error, sollte zumindest.
Da gab es halt auch wieder Probleme. Und das nächste Problem ist...
Alles, was wir jetzt sagen, alles, was wir jetzt über Technik sagen, ist die Broschüre. Nee, aber es hat mit alle Technik Probleme gegeben und auch mit alle Technik Probleme. Das glaubst du nicht mehr. Zum Beispiel mit diesen Optical Scans von Diebold in einem County hat es das Problem gegeben, dass Al Gore minus 16.022 Votes hatte.
Minus?
Minus 16.000 Votes.
Die sind dann beim Zusammenzählen ungefähr wo?
Ja, das war ein Precinct mit 412 Registered Voters und die hatten dann 2.813 Votes für Bush und minus 16.000 für Al Gore.
12.412 Voter, durchaus sportlich.
Das war Volusia County, ja komisch.
Die müssen aber echt gearbeitet haben, da eben.
Ich kann nicht vom Diebold-Chef diese Ansage damals, dass er ja auch ein Republikaner war und er die Wahlen an Bush delivern wollte oder so.
Der Punkt ist, es gibt in Amerika auch kein Audit-Infrastruktur, um diese Paper-Trail jemals nochmal anzuschauen. Auch wenn du ein Stück Papier ausfüllst und du werfst es in einen Scanner. Und der Scanner zählt danach und das Ergebnis ist eine komplette Überraschung und niemand guckt das Papier jemals mehr an, dann hast du nur ein Blackbox geschafft mit einem komischen Input-Device.
Das heißt, man sollte doch denken, ja, geile Optik, das Scanner ist doch toll, weil man hinterher noch einen richtigen Wahlzettel hat, den man einfach nachzählen kann.
Aber es wird nicht nachgezählt und das Wahlergebnis passiert dadurch, dass die Networks, die große Fernsehnetze, dann states callen. Das heißt, CBS calls Florida vor Kandidat. Und damit, wenn die Networks sich einig sind, dass ein Staat in eine Richtung gegangen ist, dann ist die Stadt fertig, dann ist die abgehakt und dann gehen wir weiter zu anderen Battlegrounds.
Und dann hören die auch auf, ihre Probleme nachzuzählen?
Dann hören die auch auf und dann ist nur für die Leute, die da für die Wahl verantwortlich sind, nur Aufgabe, dass das stimmt, mit was im Fernsehen schon gesagt worden ist.
Das heißt also, wie ist denn so ein Prozess, wenn einer der Kandidaten das Wahlergebnis anzweifelt, dann ist das was, doch richtiger Stress, ne?
Das gab es ja in Florida, das kommen wir in Ruhe aus.
Diese Optical Scan-Systeme wurden doch zumindest theoretisch die Möglichkeit bieten, dass da jemand nochmal nachzählen geht.
Die Praxis ist aber scheiße, also da gibt es dann so Fälle, wie zum Beispiel, dass es eine gültige Wahl ist, wenn du auf so einem Ankreuzzettel eben nicht ankreust, sondern den Namen des Kandidaten rausschreibst. Aber wenn du das mit einer von diesen Maschinen machst, dann sagt der halt Error. Sollte er sagen, aber was tatsächlich passiert ist, ist, dass wir den halt gefressen haben als ungültig. Und dann war deine Stimme weg. Und das erklär mal einer 90-Jährigen, die jetzt gerade ihre letzte Wahl macht. Und woher soll die das auch merken dann? Also nur diese Art von Problemen. Also Optical Scan klingt erst mal gut, aber in der Praxis ist halt auch scheiße.
Wollen wir mal die Präsidentenwahlen aufgeben?
Genau, mal so ein bisschen im Beispiel.
Wir können ja mal erzählen, wo die Kohle herkommt, mit der die Counties alle ihre Wahlmaschinen kaufen.
Ja, kommen wir dazu.
Kommen wir gleich zu.
Kommen wir da drauf. Ich hab mal so ein bisschen die letzte drei Präsidentenwahlen, mal so ein bisschen die, was da so aufmerkenswert war.
Also als Hintergrund, die Wahlen sind ja jetzt am 6. November und wir dachten uns, wir fassen mal so ein bisschen zusammen, auf was man so achten muss, indem wir halt, okay, vielleicht mal erzählen, was ist bei den bisherigen letzten drei Wahlen die typischen Probleme waren und Sachen, auf die man so hätte achten sollen, die sich dann hinterher herausgestellt haben, beziehungsweise die, denen auch teilweise erst sehr viel später rausgekommen sind.
Naja, ist auch so ein bisschen wie so eine Soap-Opera, ne, jetzt ist der, was bisher passiert, das Teil.
Ja, genau.
Also 2000, George Clavier Bush gegen Al Gore.
Ja, Al Gore war der Vise-Präsident von Bill Clinton, der hatte sein Term-Limit, der hatte schon zwei Terms. Und da hat Al Gore verloren, zwar ein Wahlmänner, aber er hat die Popular Vote gewonnen und sogar mit einer halben Million Stimmen, was echt viel ist. Da gab es dann so auch Bumper-Aufkleber, so don't blame me, I voted with the majority. Und das hat sich dann alles auf Florida konzentriert, wo es dann diese hängigen Chats gegeben hat. Das waren so diese Löcherkarten, wo dann die Chats, die Sachen, die man rausgelocht hat, sind dann hängen geblieben. Oder nur war nur eine Delle oder so halb hängen geblieben. Und das haben die Computer dann nicht richtig gezählt. Also die Zählmaschinen haben das nicht richtig gezählt. Und da müsste man eigentlich per Hand nachschauen. Und das ist dann passiert, gerade in so Counties, wo es dann Probleme gab mit Papier, was nass war. Und deswegen ist dann Florida zu Bush gegangen.
Der Gouverneur in Florida war Jeb Bush, sollten wir vielleicht dazu sagen. Der Bruder von George Bush. Insofern hat das alles eh so ein bisschen Schalen, Beigeschmack gehabt.
Ja, aber das ist dann vom Supreme Court entschieden worden, weil die Demokraten sind natürlich zur Supreme Court gegangen, haben da aber einen richtig großen Fehler gemacht. Die haben sich nämlich für deren Klagen beim Supreme Court Counties ausgesucht, wo sie ziemlich sicher waren, wenn da eine Neuzählung gibt, dann werden wir wahrscheinlich gewinnen. Und dann hat das Supreme Court das abgelehnt, weil das Cherry Picking war. Ja, jeder kann sich ein paar Counties aussuchen und hoffen, dass er damit gewinnt. Das ist Cherry Picking, da machen wir nicht mit. Und unter dem Begründung hat das Supreme Court das abgelehnt. Jetzt glauben mittlerweile alle, das wäre schwierig abzulehnen gewesen, wenn die einen Recount für ganz Florida gefragt hatten. Die Demokraten haben aber zu dem Zeitpunkt geglaubt, dass sie dann nicht sicher sind, dass sie dann noch gewinnen, wenn ganz Florida recounted wird. Haben also falsch, weil dann ist später durch eine Uni, ist das nochmal alles gemacht. Die haben sich alles geholt und haben alles nachgezählt mit Studenten ganz Florida. Und dann hatten die Demokraten gewonnen.
Das heißt, sie haben sich echt verkalkuliert?
Die haben sich verkalkuliert, ja.
Na, die haben selber versucht, einen Wahlbetrug zu machen. Na wieso, wenn du nachzählst, aber nur den Teil, der kritisiert, dass es wieder ein Valiert, also verdient, auf Deutsch verdient.
Aber es gab da andere große Sachen. Es gab da Voter-Purging. In Amerika dürfen convicted felons, Leute, die für größere Verbrechen verurteilt sind, dürfen nicht zur Wahl.
Halt, nur in manchen Staaten. Eine ganz kleine Minderheit, es sind glaube ich drei oder vier Bundesländer in den USA, haben solche Gesetze. So und jetzt, der Lacher ist eben, dass es diese Leute, dadurch, dass es keinen Personalausweis und keine Personalausweisnummer gibt, mit der man die finden könnte, es gibt nur eine Social Security Nummer und die darf per Gesetz nicht für sowas verwendet werden. Dadurch gibt es im Wahlregister nur den Namen und das Geschlecht. Und je nach Bundesland steht auch noch dran das Geburtsdatum oder Black. Also es steht dann halt auch dran. Das heißt, man kann sehen, es ist eine schwarze Frau, die ist so und so alt. Und es reicht für eine Beurteilung, statistisch gesehen, ob die jetzt Republikaner oder Demokrat gewählt haben kann. Weil nämlich relativ klar ist, erst mal Schwarze wählen, überwiegend Demokraten. Frauen wählen überwiegend, also jetzt die aktuellen Statistiken sagen, schwarze Frauen, Latinos wählen überwiegend Obama. Und das ist eben eine Sache, die ist damals in Florida aufgefallen und die EDV war soweit, das zu machen. Und die Wahlleiter haben das gemacht. Denn in den USA sind die Wahlleiter nicht unabhängig einer Behörde, sondern die werden jeweils vom Governor ernannt. Und der Gouverneur ist eben an der Stelle Jeb Bush gewesen, der wollte seinem Bruder die Wahl geben. Ja, und der hat halt ein paar alte Kumpels ernannt und die haben da eben Data-Mining betrieben und haben gesagt...
Ja, da gab es eine Firma ChoicePoint, die haben das dann gemacht.
Genau, die haben sich halt die Listen von den Fallens rausgesucht, von den Straftätern aus den Gefängnissen von diesen besagten Bundesländern. Und da steht dann halt sowas drauf wie irgendwie Bob Jones. Und dann haben sie angefangen nach Bob Jones zu suchen, die in ihrer Statistik aus Wahlbezirken kommen, die eher pro-demokratisch sind oder die eben schwarz sind. Deswegen sage ich jetzt Bob, es gab diesen einen Fall, ich habe den Nachnamen vergessen, ich glaube, es war Jones, da war es halt ein Robert und dann haben sie Bobby Jones untergeschmissen, was eine Frau war. Weil halt irgendwie Bobby und Robert, naja, close enough, also es ging nicht nach dem Namen, sondern das eigentlich Wichtige war halt irgendwie schwarz. Und dann haben wir gesagt, okay, kommt runter. Und das gibt es auch heute noch, dieses System. Dadurch, dass eben kein zentrales Register existiert, ist es nicht möglich sozusagen, dass die in Büro eine Liste ausklingt, wer wählen darf. Aber umgekehrt kann man sich hinstellen vor das Wahlbüro und einfach pauschal bei den Leuten, die da wählen kommen, anzweifeln, dass die wahlberechtigt sind. Und dann dürfen die nur ein vorübergehendes Provisional Ballot abgeben. Und das ist dann versprochen, dass das später gezählt wird. Aber wir haben ja gehört, im Grunde die Zählung hört auf, sobald CBS oder was sagt, an wen der Staat gegangen ist. Das heißt, der Konsens ist im Wesentlichen, dass diese Provisional Ballots wertlos sind. Kann man zwar abgeben, aber es spielt keine Rolle. Und das ist eben in großem Stil erstmals zur 2000er-Wahl gemacht worden. Da haben die angefangen, einfach Leute wegen ihres Namens runterzuschmeißen mit eben dieser Begründung, eine andere Begründung, die sich seitdem, ich glaube, die haben wir auch noch, ist mit den Studenten. Ja, also, kommen wir noch drauf.
Na gut, nach dieser Wahl, da war ganz Amerika sich wohl einig, dass da einiges schiefgelaufen ist. Sie waren sich nicht so sehr einig, was da schiefgelaufen ist, aber dass das alles nicht so sein sollte und zumindest nicht so aussehen sollte, da waren sich glaube ich alle einig.
Ich glaube, ChoicePoint hat auch Ärger gekriegt, oder war das nicht so?
Nach der Wahl hat es dann auch noch, dieses Wahlergebnis musste dann auch noch vom Congress, vom Federal, in Washington akzeptiert werden. Und da gab es so eine Sitzung und da darf man dann Widerspruch machen. Der Punkt ist, der Widerspruch muss dann in beide Zimmern unterstützt werden und es hat keinen Senator gegeben nach diesem Supreme Court-Urteil, der dann noch sich getraut hat, das zu widersprechen. Aber im House of Representatives hat es dann sehr viele gegeben, die dann der Vorsitzende des House of Representatives, und das war Al Gore, mit Mr. President angesprochen haben. Und diese so eine Widerspruchung, dann hat Al Gore die eine nach der andere ablehnen müssen, weil es keinen Senator dafür gibt. Also out of order und dann der nächste.
Aber er war doch selber Senator eigentlich.
Al Gore war nicht Senator.
Nein, er war Vizepräsident des Senats.
Der war Präsident des Houses.
Aber nicht selber Senator.
Der Vice President des Senators ist President of the House of Representatives.
Okay.
Welcher Senator würde das auch tun? Das müsste ja einer von den Floridianischen sein.
Die haben sich einfach nicht getraut, da noch mal eine große Nummer in der Politik zu machen, nachdem das Supreme Court sich ausgesprochen hat.
Also ich kann mich erinnern, dass alle total genervt waren, weil es sich schon seit Wochen hinzog und alle dachten, nun entscheidet euch doch einfach mal, weil es interessierte irgendwann niemanden mehr. Und ich glaube, das war eigentlich dann der eigentliche Grund.
Vor allem, weil die Demokraten sich auch blöderweise hingestellt haben und dann aufgegeben haben.
Nee, die haben sich ja nicht...
Mark Harry hat sich doch irgendwie hingestellt. Die machten nicht den Eindruck, als würden sie ernsthaft noch kämpfen wollen.
Das war zumindest so meine grobe Erinnerung. Dass es halt einfach so ein, naja, aufgeben Ding war.
Eine der Konsequenzen war eben der Help America Vote Act. Der ist relativ wichtig. Das war eben Bushs Antwort auf die Anschuldigung, er habe die Wahl manipuliert, war eben, dass man einfach mehr Wahlcomputer unters Volk bringt. Indem man den Count dieses Geld zusagt, aber nur wenn sie es für Wahlmaschinen ausgeben. Das war irgendwie der Deal, oder?
Ja, da gab es dann plötzlich 3,9 Milliarden Dollar für die Counties, um Wahlmaschinen zu kaufen, Wahltechnik zu kaufen. Nur, wenn sie es richtig schnell machen. Für die Wahlmaschinen gab es immer noch kein Gesetz, wie die denn aussehen sollten.
Und keine Zertifizierungsstandards?
Na, es gab die Voluntary Voting System Guidelines, die VVSG. Und das Wort Voluntary sagt es eigentlich schon. HAVA, die Help America Vote Act, hat dafür gesorgt, dass es eigentlich alle Counties oder viele Counties jetzt Voting Machines haben, ohne das irgendwas zu standardisieren, wie die aussehen.
Aber gab es da nicht mal diesen Versuch, dass die NIST die standardisieren sollte?
Ja, es hat mehrere Versuche gegeben, aber die Industrie hat das alles erfolgreich sabotiert.
Okay, weil...
Und es ist auch schwierig zu standardisieren, wenn es so viele unterschiedliche Arten von Wahlorganisationen gibt und so ein Zoo ist, ja dann ist es auch schwierig, da irgendwelche Standards zu schaffen.
Der Effekt ist halt von diesem Happy American Vote Act, dass jetzt quasi flächendeckend nicht mehr auf Papier gewählt wird, ne?
Naja, nicht flächendeckend, aber schon, ja. Überwiegend nicht mehr auf Papier gewählt, stimmt schon.
Also, was ich jetzt gesagt habe, war irgendwie 25 Prozent DRE ohne Paper Trail. So, und das ist ja schon dramatisch viel.
Ja, und auch einiges an DREs in Swing- oder Battleground-States, was natürlich noch schlimmer ist.
Und Optik-Escanner eigentlich quasi überall sonst und so. Ja.
Was auch noch ein wichtiger Punkt in dieser Wahl war die Rolle von Ralph Nader. Ralph Nader ist so ein Consumer Advocate in den Vereinigten Staaten.
Verbraucherschütze.
Verbraucherschütze, einer der originalen Verbraucherschütze, hat viele, vieles...
Der hat den Sicherheitsgurt unter die Autos gebracht.
Zum Beispiel, der ist richtig bekannt. Und wir haben von zwei Parteien-System geredet. The Green Party, wo er dann quasi Listenführer war, hat zu dem Zeitpunkt in dem Wahl in 2000, als das Al Gore gegen Bush war, auch echt viele Stimmen bekommen. Der hat zu dem Zeitpunkt fast drei Millionen Stimmen bekommen. Und die Republikaner dann 50 und die Demokraten 51. Aber er hat dann mehrere Prozente der Stimmen gehabt. Und es ist ihm immer nachgetragen geworden, dass er dafür gesorgt hat, dass jetzt Bush Präsident ist, weil er hatte auch genug Stimmen in Florida und diverse Battleground States. Natürlich hatte er mehr Stimmen da, wo die Leute das Gefühl haben, sie können in Frieden eine Proteststimme abgeben, weil eh nichts entscheidend. Aber auch genug in Battleground States, um Gore die Wahl gekostet zu haben.
Wobei das war das so eine Verschwörungstheorie, die die Republikaner nun aufgesetzt haben, um auf jemand anderes zu zeigen.
Ja, es hat dazu geführt, dass Naders Profil im progressiven Amerika ziemlich schlecht ist. Weil alle Leute ihm vorwerfen, dass er dafür gesorgt hat, dass George Bush an der Macht kam. Das ist also auch andere Kräfte, als man normalerweise so denkt, führen zu diesem Zwei-Parteiensystem.
Ja klar, wenn du halt nur eine marginale Partei und ein Zwei-Parteiensystem bist, die im Zweifel dann der etwas weniger...
Bei uns bist du dann der Koalitionspartner.
Genau, bei uns wärst du der Koalitionspartner.
Genau.
Das wäre tatsächlich der Effekt gewesen. Dann hättest du halt irgendwie Democrats Green gegeben. Interessant.
Ja, nun wird es 2004, die nächste Präsidentswahl. Inzwischen gibt es natürlich immer noch... Alle zwei Jahre gibt es diese House of Representatives-Wahl, aber die skippen wir mal.
Also was man vielleicht noch sagen sollte, bei der 2000er-Wahl die Wahlbeteiligung knapp über 50 Prozent. Also auch noch mal deutlich weniger als bei uns.
Ja. Das war dann in 2004 schon 56 Prozent.
Moment, wenn wir sagen, wir haben 50 Prozent Wahlbeteiligung und wir haben überhaupt nur in 20 Prozent der Wähler tatsächlich einen Einfluss auf die Wahl, ja, das ist ja multiplikativ. Das heißt, wir haben am Ende 10 Prozent und davon...
10 Prozent der Wahlberechtigte haben überhaupt...
Am Ende entscheidet so eine Stadt wie New York von der Anzahl der Einwohner her für das ganze Land.
Nur, dass es nicht New York ist, sondern Iowa.
So ein fetter Himmel, nur dass es halt verteilt ist. Das ist schon ziemlich krass eigentlich, wenn man nur mal nachdenkt, ne?
Aber gut, 2004, da war George Bush als Incumbent, der saß da als Präsident und da war John Kerry der Demokraten. Das hat Bush gewonnen. 62 Millionen... Na ja... 62 Millionen, 59 Millionen. 56 Prozent Wahlbeteiligung, wie schon gesagt. Ja, da gab es knappe Winne. In Iowa, New Mexico.
Das war die Swift-Boat-Geschichte.
Ja, ja.
Swift-Boat war wirklich heftig. Das war eine...
Ja, Swift-Boat war heftig, aber auch die Frage war auch, was mit Bush Wehrpflicht ist, ne?
Da stimme ich mich nicht überein mit deiner Zusammenfassung, dass die Dokumente eine klare Fälschung sind. Also das bestreitet zumindest die Quelle von den Dokumenten bis heute.
Dann sollten wir die Geschichte dazu erzählen.
Die Geschichte?
Genau, erzählen wir die Geschichte. Die Frage in dieser Wahl war, die Republikaner hatten ein Problem. Weil George Bush hatte so quasi Dienst verweigert. Der war von Papa bei der Air National Guard geschickt.
Geparkt worden, ja?
Geparkt worden.
Und zwar von Texas. Die National Guard von Texas, während des Vietnamkriegs hat Bush heldenhaft den Luftraum von Texas verteidigt, während die anderen alle in Vietnam verbrannt wurden.
Und sogar das hat er nicht wirklich getan, weil er es ein paar Mal hingegangen hat, aber es war auch wieder schon gut. Bush, es hat sich also quasi für Vietnam gedrückt. Er ist von Papa irgendwo hingesetzt worden, wo er nicht erschossen wurde. Während Carrie ein dekorierter Vietnam-Held war. Der war Offizier auf so Swiftboats. Das waren die kleine Patrouilleschiffe, die dann auf die Jungleflüsse in Vietnam herumgefahren sind. Und der hat dann auch noch Leute gerettet. Der kam mit einem Purple-Cross, der war so richtig ein Kriegsheld. Das war für die Republikaner natürlich ein Problem. Das hat dann dazu geführt, dass es Dan Rather, ein Journalist bei CBS damals, sind dann Dokumente zugespielt worden, die dann nachweisen sollten, dass Bush auch wirklich AWOL war. Absent Without Leave. Die Dokumente haben sich dann, du sagst nicht...
Dass er nicht mal hingegangen ist.
Dass er nicht mal hingegangen ist. Die Dokumente haben sich dann als Fälschung...
Also der Major Consensus Narrative am Ende war das.
Genau, der Major Consensus Narrative, das war eine Fälschung. Aber der Nachweis ist erbracht worden, indem sie zu den Militärdienst hingegangen sind und gesagt haben, zeig uns doch mal die Dokumente, weil da nämlich Notizen liegen müssten, wenn er AWOL ist und da war halt ein leerer Schrank. Und dann haben sie gesagt, also offensichtlich ist der Busch ein ehrenwerter Militäranhänger gewesen und der ist nicht AWOL gewesen, sonst müsste man hier noch Unterlagen finden. So der Schredder war noch schön warm gelaufen. Also das ist alles nicht so einfach, da die Wahrheit zu finden. Aber es gab halt eine wirklich böseartige Kampagne gegen Carey, nämlich die Swiftboaters.
Ja, das ist jetzt auch ein Wort geworden. Man kann jemanden Swiftboaten. Swiftboating heißt, es hat da eine Gruppe gegeben, das Swift Vets and POWs for Truth. Eine Gruppe Vietnam-Veteranen, die dann mal die Wahrheit sagen wollte und so in die Presse immer wieder gesagt haben, da war kein Vietnam-Held und der tut nur als Ob. Und die haben dann so eine Reihe von...
Das war dann ein fetter Werbespot, der im Fernsehen rauf und runter lief. Ein Päck hat das bezahlt und der Päck hieß Swift Vets and POWs for Truth. Also das war genau wie man heute irgendwie sagen würde, Citizens for a Better American Future and Children, bla bla bla. Hießen die damals eben die Swift Boat Veterans.
Und es war eigentlich nur Black Propaganda.
Das war übelste Propaganda.
Phony War Crimes Charges, his exaggerated claims about his own service in Vietnam and his deliberate misrepresentation of the nature and effectiveness of Swift Boat Operations compels us to step forward. Das waren also die richtigen Helden, die mal erzählt haben, dass das mit der Carrie alles nicht so schön war, wie er selber behauptet.
Klassischer Althominem, ne? Ging ja gar nicht um Vietnam, es ging darum, Carrie mit Schmutz zu bewerfen.
Genau. Aber mit Wahlcomputern hat es auch einige Probleme.
Genau, es war sozusagen nach dem Half-American-Vote-Act, ne?
Ja, genau.
Da hätte eigentlich alles perfekt laufen müssen.
Ja, aber es gibt eine Liste mit Inzidenz, die ist so lang, da hab ich nur...
Nimm doch mal dein Lieblingsinzident.
Lieblingsinzident, naja, es gab der Ohio Secretary of State, Kenneth Blackwell, die war sowohl Co-Chair of the 2004 Republican Presidential Campaign als auch Ohio Secretary of State, also Wahlorganisator für Ohio, einer der heißesten Battleground States, the Battleground State of Battleground States.
Und der hat öffentlich angesagt, der werde die Wahl an Bush delivern.
Nee, das war der former President of the Diebold Election Systems. Auch, auch! Das hat mehr als einer gesagt. Der hat sogar gesagt, in a fundraising letter for George W. Bush hat er gesagt, he was committed to helping Ohio deliver its electoral votes to the President. Und das ist der Präsident von der Wahlmaschinenfirma.
Wobei diese Wahlmaschinenfirmen eigentlich alle aus dem republikaner Umfeld kommen. Insofern erklärt sich auch der Help America Vote Act ein bisschen. Also da ging es nicht darum, ist uns eigentlich egal, welche ihr kauft, weil am Ende kauft ihr immer eine von uns.
Da war ein Republican Senator, war Chairman of ESNS, hatte andere große Votingmaschinenfirma. Es gab Diebold, die hatten dann five convicted felons as consultants and developers. Also Kriminellen, verurteilte Kriminellen.
Die nicht wählen dürfen, durften aber Wahlmaschinen bauen.
Aber Wahlmaschinen developpen. Ja klar. The Senior Vice President of Global Election Systems was convicted of 23 counts of felony theft in the first degree. Und das steht noch dabei. Convicted of theft via quote alteration of records in the computerized accounting system using a quote high degree of sophistication to evade detection. Naja, das ist der Tote.
Genau der, den man haben will für Wahlmaschinen.
Ich glaube, wir sollten nicht so viel Englisch zitieren, weil wir brauchen eigentlich ein deutscher Podcast.
Ja, beide nicht meine Muttersprache. Das eine live aufs andere ersetzen ist mir doch ein bisschen schwierig.
Ja, also interessant war, dass in dieser Wahl waren es tatsächlich 30 Prozent der Stimmen, die mit TRI-Maschinen, also mit rein elektronischen Maschinen, ohne paper trail gemacht wurden. Das heißt, tatsächlich noch mehr als jetzt bei der nächsten Wahl sein werden.
Ja, und man sah auch fürs erste Mal eine richtige Diskrepanz Richtung Bush. Da, wo mit Touchscreen, mit Direct Recording, Elektronik-Maschinen gewählt wurde, da kommen wir später noch drauf. Das nennt sich dann Redshift. Aber da haben wir später noch eine ganzes...
Diese Touchscreen-Geschichten können wir vielleicht gerade mal einschieben. Also, welche Betrugsmechanismen gibt es bei Touchscreen-Maschinen? Einen hatten wir gerade, hattest du gerade geblockt in Belgien, wo es mehrere Wahlen gab und man dachte, naja, wenn du halt die Partei wählen willst, dann drückst du halt ein paar Mal auf dieselbe Stelle. Aber das Layout ist halt so gemacht.
Hat sich geändert, ja?
Ja, genau. Das Layout änderte sich halt so, dass du halt tatsächlich hingucken musstest. Und wenn du dann keinen Paypal-Trial hast, dann naja, ist halt blub, ist halt weg, ist halt gestimmt. Und dann gibt es natürlich die Probleme mit der Kalibrierung. Also, dass du halt, wenn du auf den Touchscreen drückst... Man kennt jetzt zum Beispiel von den typischen Fahrkartenautomaten. Also da hat man ja so als Hilfe, wenn man draufdrückt, so einen kleinen roten oder weißen Punkt, der zeigt, was er jetzt meint, wo der Finger war. Und gerade im Winter zum Beispiel oder auch im Sommer, wenn es richtig heiß und schwül ist, dann ist der Finger gerne mal, also der Punkt...
Zentimeter weiter oben.
Zentimeter weiter oben, ne. Und wenn man jetzt sich überlegt, dass man damit wählen soll, dann wird die Sache halt schon durchaus interessant. Dann gibt es natürlich noch eine Menge andere Probleme, wie zum Beispiel, wenn es halt reine DIY-Maschinen sind und die genau in dem Augenblick abstürzen, wo man halt sagt, jetzt möchte ich aber gewählt haben, dann weiß man immer noch nicht, ob die Stimme jetzt irgendwie im Speicher ist oder nicht. Und interessant fand ich auch, dass viele von diesen Touchscreen-Maschinen echt winzige Bildschirme haben, wo die dann richtig viel so Auswahlmöglichkeiten in ganz kleiner Schrift drauf haben. Also man denkt ja, okay, so ein Touchscreen, wenn man jetzt so vier Wahlmöglichkeiten hat, dann macht man die so richtig groß, aber nein, da sind es teilweise ganz kleine Button, wo man dann immer noch eine Lüppe braucht, um die zu erkennen.
Na und wo du verloren hast, wenn du Alterssiehbehindert bist.
Na klar.
Aber in 2004 haben die ganze Probleme mit Wahlcomputern, obwohl es viele waren, echt viele, haben nicht zu viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommen, weil die Wahl halt nicht so knapp war. Das Wahlergebnis war nirgendwo richtig knapp. Weil am Ende Carrie nicht sehr beliebt war.
Das kommt auf die Perspektive an. Also ich war gerade in Amerika zu dem Zeitpunkt und war auf einer John-Carrie-Wahl-Feier, weil sich im Grunde alle, die ich da kannte, einig waren, dass Carrie jetzt mit Abstand gewinnen würde. Und das war einer der traurigsten Partys, weil vorne war halt so ein riesiger Bildschirm, wo sie dann da mit Projektoren die News ranprojizierten und die callten dann einen Start nach dem anderen. Und dann am Ende haben sie halt umgeschwenkt, weil eben auch gleichzeitig Wahl war für den Gouverneur. Und die ging ein bisschen besser aus. Und die ging ein bisschen, da hatten die Demokraten noch eine Chance. Aber es war wirklich die traurigste Sache überhaupt. Und vorne habe ich dann noch so einen Button mitgenommen, I voted, was sie halt so wollen, halt die Leute incentivieren, damit sie wählen.
Dann mussten sie sich dann schlimm betrinken.
Die haben sich übel betrunken am Ende. Was willst du da auch machen? Aber keineswegs war aus meiner Perspektive da das nicht irgendwie Hauptthema, dass die natürlich alle beschissen haben mit den Wahlcomputern. Aber Kerry, der Vollidiot, Kerry hat sich nach drei Tagen hingestellt und die Wahl aufgegeben, hat Conceded, zu Bush gegangen und hat gesagt, herzlichen Glückwunsch Herr Bush, die haben gewonnen. Und danach kam die Hälfte von diesen Geschichten erst raus. Aber da hat dann keiner mehr die Energie gehabt, da was zu machen. Also das habe ich ganz anders erlebt damals. Aber ist ja auch egal. Kerry, ich weiß nicht, ob das besser gewesen wäre, damit das war halt, ja auch nicht.
Auf jeden Fall hat er keine große Aufmerksamkeit bekommen, außer in so einem Kreis von Leuten, die sie mit Wahlen beschäftigt haben. Da ist dann doch einiges passiert. Es gab dann diese neue Volatil guidelines, um die Industrie mal so ein bisschen zu incentivieren, doch Wahlmaschinen zu bauen, die vielleicht nicht so ganz scheiße waren. Und es hat in Kalifornien und in Ohio große Reviews gegeben, die die Industrie eigentlich feindlich waren. Und das war fürs erste Mal. In Kalifornien ist dann Deborah Bowen zur Secretary of State gewählt worden. Und Deborah Bowen ist schon cool. Die ist gewählt worden, auch auf dem Plattformen. Ich schau da mal rein. Ich will da mal wissen, was in unserer Wahlmaschine überhaupt passiert. Und das ist einer der Gründe, dass die Wähler sie gewählt haben. Und sie hat dann die California Top-to-Bottom-Review, die TTBR, angeordert und hat sich Wissenschaftler aus ganz Amerika geholt, die dann für den Staat Kalifornien, das Angestellte der Stadt Kalifornien, weil es dürfte ja niemand extern sich die...
Stimmt, die Industrie hat sich ja noch richtig gesträubt. Die wollten auch so gar nicht, dass da einer richtig reinguckt.
Aber Kalifornien hat einfach gesagt, wenn sie nicht mitarbeiten werden in ihrer Maschine, sowieso desertified, dürfen sie also nicht mehr im Wahl eingesetzt werden. Also die haben mitarbeiten müssen. Dafür dürfte den Staat Kalifornien dann natürlich keine freie Mitarbeiter, nichts, weil die würden dann Sourcecode sehen und alles. Haben dann quasi die besten Wissenschaftler Amerikas um diesen Thema zur temporären Mitarbeiter der Staat Kalifornien gemacht.
Und das war vernichtend, oder?
Das war komplett vernichtend. Bowen hat dann quasi für eine Reihe von Wahlcomputern die Zertifizierung einfach weggenommen, andere nur für ganz eingegrenzte Gruppen von Wähler zugelassen. Zum Beispiel die Maschinen, die dann für behinderte Wähler besser waren als Papier. Hat sie denn nur einen Wahlcomputer pro Wahllokal und nur für Behinderten? Also sie hatte wirklich, diese Wahl war Kalifornien wieder ganz viel Papier, weil sie einfach für alle Diaries zum Beispiel die Genehmigung eingezogen hat. Und ich war dann, ich war im Raum in so einer Konferenz in Deutschland, als dann die ganzen Amis da waren, die das dann gemacht hatten, die Top to Bottom Review und das Paper kam raus oder das Ergebnis kam raus. Und wir hatten so das Gefühl, jetzt wird sich was ändern. Die Industrie hat jetzt wirklich klop bekommen. Jetzt kriegen Leute mit, dass das über die ganze Linie nicht stimmt. Weil die California Top to Bottom Review hat quasi für die ganze Industrie, weil da waren fast alle Maschinen im Use, die haben für die ganze Industrie einfach mal gezeigt, das ist nicht nur Inzident, das ist flächendeckend Schrott. Da wird nur Schrott geliefert und da gab es auch so richtig komische Probleme. Da gab es Scripting Languages in Barcodes. Einfach alles, was man sich ausdenken kann, dass man falsch machen kann, war da falsch gemacht. In Ohio gab es das gleiche, Everest hat sich das genannt. Aber das Gefühl war wirklich, es wird sich was ändern. Und da gab es in 2008 vor der Präsidentenwahl in Auto Mai die Sequoia-Maschinen, Ed Felten, wie schon erwähnt in New Jersey, diese nederabhängigen Maschinen, da gab es echt viel Aufmerksamkeit. Und das war dann auch gleichzeitig mit diese ganzen Wahlcomputersachen hier in Europa, als hier in Deutschland und in Holland Wahlcomputern gehackt wurden. Es gab so, weltweit gab es das Gefühl, endlich kippt die Sache mal. Das war dann doch aber nicht, weil eigentlich ist alles wieder zertifiziert, sind nur ganz kleine Sachen gefixt und hat sich im ganzen Groben nichts geändert.
Also zumindest in den USA.
Zumindest in den USA. Hier sind die Wahlcomputer weg, aber in den USA hat sich für diese Sache nichts geändert. Ja, dann war es 2008. Dann kam der Wahl Barack Obama versus John McCain. Dann dürfte ja Bush nicht mehr Wahltermlimit. Und ich glaube, Amerika wollte ihm auch nicht zu mir. Bushes Approval-Ratings waren die letzten paar Jahre 25 bis 35 Prozent.
Am Ende waren sie eher so bei 10 Prozent. Das war richtig doll schlimm. Es gab irgendwie so ein schönes Cartoon, wo sie gezeigt haben, dass Malaria Mosquitos ein höheres Approval-Rating als Bush hatten. Also das ging wirklich gar nicht. Telemarketer waren beliebter als Bush.
Die ganzen Republikaner in der Wahlkampf haben sich auch, John McCain hat sich bemüht, nicht mit Bush gesehen zu werden, den Namen nicht zu erwähnen, zu tun, als wäre das ein anderer Planeten, eine andere Partei.
Ist ja jetzt wieder. Die Republikaner sind auch sehr bemüht. Bush war auch nicht eingeladen zu den Primaries und so. Oder doch, er war glaube ich eingeladen, aber konnte nicht auf so irgendwelche Vorgeschrubbungen.
Es war auch die Wahl, dass Obama versus Hillary Clinton war in den Primaries. Hillary Clinton war die Favoritekandidaten und dann ist doch Obama geworden. Romney war auch dabei, eben beim Republikaner und auch Ron Paul, wie jetzt auch wieder. Und es war die Election mit Sarah Palin. Von John McCain, als seine Running Maid gewählt wurde. Sarah Palin für die Wähler, die sich nicht erinnern, war die Frau, die von Alaska aus Russland sehen kann. Die von Alaska aus Russland sehen kann und vielleicht, wo es auch vielleicht etwas zu sichtbar war zu dem Zeitpunkt auf jeden Fall, dass sie vielleicht doch nicht derjenige sein sollte, die Präsidentin werden sollte, wenn mit John McCain, der schon richtig alt war, mal ein Unfall passiert.
Das war doch immer der Witz über die Jahre, warum es keinen Terroranschlag gegen Bush gab, weil sonst Dick Cheney über Nobben jetzt jetzt... Oh mein Gott, oh mein Gott.
Der interessante, interessante Nervoll war, dass zum einen die Wahlbeteiligung sehr hoch war, also 63 Prozent.
Naja, sehr hoch.
Naja, für die Verhältnisse. Und das ist Ergebnis doch irgendwie so groß und also die Differenz im Ergebnis war so groß, dass alle Betrugsversuche, die da wo stattgefunden haben, sind vertrunken. Was war das? 365 zu 173 Wahlmänner und sowas wie 69 Millionen zu 60 Millionen Stimmen.
Also ein Landslide-Victory in die Amerikaner. Das ist ja wirklich noch so komisch. Da gab es Libertaria-Kandidaten in Texas.
Habt ihr das eigentlich im Fernsehen beobachtet, die Wahl damals? Da hatte ich so einen Moment, wo ich dachte, das bin ich im falschen Film. Weil die ARD hat das natürlich direkt gebracht, gesagt so. Obama ist es. Florida has called, bla bla. Und dann haben sie eine Live-Übertragung nach Amerika gemacht zu Obamas Wahlparty und da lief Werbung. Die hatten diese Nachricht noch nicht gekriegt, weil da Werbung lief auf der Wahlparty, lief auf dem fetten Bildschirm. Werbung für irgendeine Scheiße. Und dann der ARD-Reporter war sichtlich irritiert. Und ja, also jeden Moment muss das hier kommen. Und dann saßen wir da vor dem Fernsehen und so, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Und dann kam halt vorne so und so gecalled und ein riesiges Jubel. Unglaublich. Also wir in Deutschland haben es erfahren, bevor die Abrikales erfahren haben. Das war echt der Bruder.
War noch lustig, dass die beiden Campaigns, sowohl Obama als McCain, haben angeblich zu spät in Texas angemeldet. Da wollte also jemand aus einem anderen Partei, wollte die beiden Kandidaten runter haben von der Liste. Und es ist dann vom Texas Supreme Court abgelehnt worden, aber ohne Begründung.
Das war schon mal... Geht nicht.
Oh, schon so spät?
Es war auch, was ein großes Problem war zu diesem Wahl, und was wir vielleicht mal nennen, war Caging. Caging ist da viel passiert und Caging gehört zu dem Challenging dazu. Vielleicht sollen wir die beiden mal erwähnen. In Amerika gibt es, wie gesagt, nicht ein zentrales Register, der wir wählen darf, da gibt es diesen, man ist registrierter Wähler, und registrierter Wähler sind registriert mit einer Adresse, und da darf ein Campaign Post hinschicken. Und wenn der Post dann als unbestellbar zurückkommt, dann ist das ausreichend Grund, um anzweifeln zu dürfen, ob diese Person da noch wohnt und deswegen, ob der noch zur Wahl gehen darf. Und man kann verursachen, dass die Post zurückgeschickt wird, dadurch, dass man zum Beispiel die Do-Not-Forward draufschreibt. Und dadurch, dass es ein bisschen wie Spam aussieht. Weil es gibt zum Beispiel, wenn man seinen Post holt, gibt es schon ein Postfach für alles, was zurück muss, weil der Person hier schon nicht mehr wohnt oder so. Und viele Leute werfen in so einem Fach auch deren Spam. Also wenn es aus Spam aussieht, dann werft ihr das gerne da rein, weil dann kriegt er den Post wieder. Und zum Beispiel Studenten sind dann oft im Sommer zum Beispiel zu Hause und kommt der Post wieder. Also die Caging kann man machen, wenn man eine Population definieren kann von Leuten, die vielleicht nicht zur Wahl gehen dürfen.
Und keine eigenen Briefkasten haben.
Und wenn man Republikaner ist, dann will man nicht, dass Studenten zur Wahl gehen. Weil die wählen meistens demokratisch, man will nicht, dass...
Bei den Demokraten, die wollen wahrscheinlich, dass die Altersheimbewohner wählen gehen.
Nee, nee, nee. Also die normalen Alte wählen auch Demokraten. Ja, also das sind nur die reichen Alten, die die Republikaner wählen. Aber so die normalen Altersheiminsassen, daher gibt es auch diesen Bias mit den Wahlmaschinen, die irgendwie kleine Fonds haben. Ja, das halte ich auch nicht für Zufall. Sondern da geht es ganz klar darum, bestimmte Bevölkerungsschichten am Wählen zu hindern.
In diesem Fall trifft es auch Soldaten, die gerade mit dem Einsatz sind.
Ja, die sind sowieso eine eigene Kategorie, denn die müssen Briefwahlen machen, aber die haben keine normale Post, sondern die haben Feldpost. Und das ist so eine Spezialabhängung des Militärs, die bekannt dafür ist, dass das schon mal ein bisschen länger dauert und dass da Sachen verloren gehen. Und da sind eben überproportional auf diesen Caging-Listen vertreten, sind eben a. Studenten und b. alte Leute. Wenn jemand irgendwie alt und gebrechlich ist und seinen Briefkasten nur alle zwei Tage leert und da ist viel Spam drin, dann kommt das eben auch mal zurück, weil der Briefkasten war voll. Und die Soldaten, da gab es sogar so einen Fall, da sind über eine halbe Million von den von den Soldaten abgegebenen Briefwahlstimmen einfach nicht berücksichtigt worden. In nur einem Staat war das, Florida, wenn ich mich richtig in den Sinn erinnere.
Und wählen die dann nicht irgendwie Primäre Republikaner?
Die Soldaten, da würde man denken, weil die Republikaner so militärfreundlich sind, aber ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, wenn du im Krieg bist und siehst, wie scheiße das alles ist und sinnlos, dass du dir dann irgendwie schon eine Frage stellst.
Und gerade in der Obama-Wahl, Obama-McCain war Obamas großer Thema, war Bring the Boys Back Home.
Und das wird schon populär sein. Und jetzt ist es glaube ich andersrum, jetzt sagen ja beide Bring the Boys Back Home. Romney sagt jetzt sowieso alles, wenn die Kamera gerade auf ihr zeigt. Aber jetzt ist ja auch Barack Obama der Obervorsitzende des Militärs. Also das ist auch ihren Grund selbst für so eigentlich traditionelle Republikanerwähler, ihr Chain of Command zu wählen.
Tja, naja, keine Ahnung.
Na, man weiß es nicht. Aber also das sind schon Zahlen, da kann man nicht mehr von irgendwie, ach naja, das kann ja mal passieren, reden, wenn eine halbe Million Stimmen verloren gehen. Na gut, also Caging ist auch jetzt noch ein Thema. Ist eher noch ausgeweitet worden. Wir kommen zu den Wahlen 2012. Obama gegen mit Romney. Der Zwischenstand sieht so aus, dass die meisten Stimmen für Romney sind. Knapp natürlich, aber ein Prozent Unterschied.
Also wozu man sagen muss, dass wir befinden uns jetzt halt gerade im klar im Fehlerbereich von Umfragen. Also so die Ami-Umfragen ist interessant. Die haben alle eine sehr viel höhere Fehlerrate als die Umfragen in Deutschland. So in Deutschland werden die Wahlumfragen so je nach Institut so zwischen zweieinhalb und drei Prozent Fehlerrate angegeben. Und in Amiland sagen sie irgendwas zwischen fünf und sieben Prozent.
Lustigerweise gibt es auch, sowohl hier wie drüben gibt es verschiedene Umfragebüros, die sich dann auch quasi spezialisierte Kundenkreise haben. Und der, der von Fox News befragt wird, hat eigentlich immer geringfügig bessere Werte wie die Republikaner, als der, der von CNN befragt wird. Das ist auch so ein Effekt, wo man sich denkt, aber das gibt es in Deutschland auch.
Na ja klar, Halleinsbach versus Forza und so. Genau, ja diese Geschichten. Interessant dabei finde ich, dass der, also man konnte ja bis von einer Weile noch immer so die Zockerbörsen, so wie Intrade, benutzen, wo man auf den Wahlgewinn wetten konnte und hat da doch, also zumindest so die letzten acht Jahre, so ungefähr eine relativ präzise Vorhersage des zumindest des Popular-Vote-Wahl-Ergebnisses gehabt. Und ist jetzt vorbei, weil die High-Frequency-Trader auch angefangen haben, auf Intrade zu zocken und den anderen derartigen Börsen.
Machen alles kaputt!
Deswegen ist die Vorhersagequalität von diesen Börsen mittlerweile auch leider etwas eingeschränkt, was ein bisschen schade ist. Was haben wir denn zu erwarten für diese Wahl?
Naja, wie gesagt, Popular-Vote, Romney plus ein Prozent, aber Wahlmänner hat Obama immer noch 290 und Romney 248. Aber Obama würde, wenn es bei dem Zwischenstand von gestern bleibt und wenn es nicht große Fehlermargen gibt an die Umfragen, würde Obama neu gewählt werden.
Das heißt, wenn er genügend Stimmen kriegt, um den Fraud-Margin der anderen Seite zu überwinden.
Gut, wir kommen zum Fraud-Margin. Was ist denn ein Fraud-Margin?
Na, der Fraud-Margin ist, wie viel Wahlbetrug kann dann die andere Seite mobilisieren, sei es halt durch Wahlcomputerbetrug oder Wählerabschreckung oder Zählbetrug oder was auch immer die möglichen Dinge sind. Und da scheint mir doch so bei diesen Wahlen, dass der mögliche Fraud-Margin von Romney, also von Romneys Seite, doch irgendwie eher dramatisch angestiegen ist. Also zumindest, wenn man sich so anguckt, so die Wahlcomputerhersteller gehören teilweise direkt Romney, also seiner Familie.
Ja, da gibt es Hard InterCivic. Die haben Diaries und andere Systeme in mehreren Swing States im Einsatz. Alles komplett unsicher. Das ist auch die Firma, wo es wahrscheinlich dieses noch immer dieses Problem gibt. Mit einem Voter bekommt ein Optical Readable Barcode, um sich bei einer dieser viele Wahlmaschinen in diese Sporthalle zu melden. Und diese Barcode enthält wahrscheinlich ein Scripting Language, immer noch was auch andere Sachen machen kann, als nur erzählen, in welche Sprache er gerade sein Ballot haben soll.
Weißt du, wir haben ja vor ein paar Jahren mal so einen Vortrag über Barcodes auf dem Kongress gehabt von der Felix, weißt du, änderst du dich? Ja, also das ist ganz toll. Aber was man als Nerd hinnehmen muss...
Aber HIG Capital, so eine Venture Capital Firma, die haben jetzt das größte Teil von Hard InterCivic. Und Hard InterCivic ist also unter anderem ist das Tag Romney, Romney's Sohn, ist da jetzt der Boss. Das merken die nie?
Ich meine, ich finde es immer krass, dass man sowas, wir lesen hier sowas im Web und fragen uns immer, nehmen wir mal an, das wäre jetzt mit Putin passiert. Putins Sohn hätte Wahlmaschinenfirma gekauft. Ich meine, da wäre doch die Hölle los.
Solomir Capital, das ist die Investmentfirma von Mitt Romney Sohn Tagg. Und da gibt es auch noch Geld in einem Closely Held Firm, wie auch immer das auch Deutsch heißt, von Taggs Onkel Scott, Mutter Anne und von Mitt Romney selber. Na toll.
Das ist alles scheiße. Na warte mal, du hast jetzt hier noch ein anderes Ding übers Scrawl2Watsch. Also wir kommen langsam zu den verschiedenen Verfahren, wie man Wahlen mit Wahlcomputern, selbst wenn sie gut sind, bescheißt. Denn das ist eine Lektion, die ich wichtig finde an der Stelle. Wir als Nerds fokussieren uns ja ganz gerne auf so die technischen Angreifbarkeiten von den Maschinen. Dass man irgendwelche Abstrahlung misst und so. Aber die Leute, die bei den Wahlen bescheißen wollen, das sind ja keine Technik-Nerds. Das heißt, die greifen eher strukturelle Sachen an. Das heißt, was wir beobachten können, ist zum Beispiel sowas wie, in demokratischen Wahlbezirken steht dann irgendwie pro 1000 Leute eine Wahlmaschine und in republikanischen Bezirken stehen drei Wahlmaschinen. Und die bei den Republikanern, da kann man irgendwie ein Touchscreen und klickt irgendwie an. Und die bei den demokratischen Wahlbezirken, die armen schwarzen Viertel, ist dann so eine Stanzmaschine, wo es dann mit Chats Probleme gibt oder wo es ungültige Wahlsachen gibt, wo man was falsch klicken kann.
Oder die Wahlkomputer sind einfach langsam, oder?
Oder die sind einfach langsam, genau. Oder es gibt Ausfälle, weil das Klimascheiße ist.
Da hört man einfach zu wenig.
Diese Art von strukturellen Problemen treffen einfach überproportional die ärmeren Bevölkerungsschichten, die Einwanderer, also die schwarzen Gettos. Und das sind Demokratenwähler.
Also das ist so interessant, also bei diesen Diskussionen um die Standardisierung von diesen Wahlcomputern, wir sollten, glaube ich, mehr Wahlcomputer sagen, war eines der Dinge, die am härtesten bekämpft wurde von der Industrie, war der Versuch, genau die Zeit für einen Vot zu begrenzen. Also was man gesagt hat, okay, also in einem Test mit einer großen Gruppe von Wählern, die wollten dann so eher so 1000 Wähler und nicht nur so 20 oder so, muss im Schnitt eine Standardwahl, diese halt sozusagen als Standardtestwahl haben, innerhalb von vier Minuten oder so machbar sein. Und das war die Klausel, wo sich die, alle diese Firmen mit Händen und Füßen gegengewehrt haben, wo sie auf gar keinen Fall ran wollten, weil offensichtlich genau diese Zeit, die es braucht, bis halt so eine Stimme abgegeben ist, eben ein erhebliches Manipulationstool ist.
Also ich erinnere mich noch an Videos von der Wahl, als ich drüben war. Und da gab es so Effekte, wie, also ich habe ja bereits gesagt, dass die Wahlen einen Wochentag stattfinden, wo die Leute möglicherweise ihren Job unterbrechen und nicht bezahlt werden für die Zeit, wo die einen Ausfall hinnehmen müssen. Und da gab es so Wahlbezirke, wo es dann sechs bis acht Stunden Warteschlange gab vor dem Wahlbüro, weil die Leute alle wählen wollten. Aber die haben halt, naja, absichtlich, das nehme ich jetzt mal an, aber man weiß natürlich nicht, zu wenig und zu schlechtes Equipment stand und das alles ewig dauerte. Und dann gibt es dann natürlich die Wahlbüros, die machen auch irgendwann zu. Das heißt, da gab es dann Geschichten, dass die Wahlbüros ausnahmsweise noch ein paar Stunden offen geblieben sind, damit die Leute alle wählen können. Aber ich meine, würdet ihr das in Kauf nehmen, wenn ihr wählen wollt für die Bundestagswahl, die müsste acht Stunden lang in der Kälte stehen? Das ist doch völlig unzumutbar. Es war doch kein Sommer, nicht mal am Wochenende hier bei uns, aber jetzt am Wochentag auch noch. Und nun haben wir in Amerika gerade eine Rezession, wo die Leute alle so Mac-Jobs haben, wo sie dann zwei bis vier von haben, damit sie ihre Familie durchbringen können. Das heißt, das ist ein richtig ernstzunehmender Ausfall, von dem wir da reden.
Und sie haben jetzt noch richtiges Scheißwetter.
Und jetzt gibt es auch noch diesen Hurricane, der bietet sich ja geradezu an für so eine Cajun-Geschichte. Weil dann kommt die Mail zurück, weil der Briefkasten nicht geleert wurde, weil die Leute gerade evakuiert sind.
Und die Leute haben natürlich auch keine Lust, halt irgendwie im Wintersturm vor dem Wahllokal zu stehen.
Nee, aber bis dahin ist ja hoffentlich vorbei.
Na ja, mal gucken, scheint eine Weile anzudauern.
Early Voting läuft jetzt schon.
Ja, das stimmt, Early Voting läuft jetzt schon. Die haben ja teilweise die Early Voting-Lokale schon geschlossen. Das ist wegen dem Sturm.
Gut, aber es ist ja New York, da wissen wir eh wieder.
Aber ich meine, man sollte doch denken, in so normalen zivilisierten Gesellschaften würden solche Sachen doch eigentlich auffallen. Also da gibt es sowas wie Wahlbeobachter und Leute, die sich darum kümmern und irgendwie Berichte darüber so. Und warum ist das denn ein großer Hals so?
Vielleicht mal gut zu reden, was ist eigentlich ein ehrlicher Wahl? Was gehört denn dazu? Und da gibt es also mehrere internationale Organisationen und Gremien, die mal drüber nachdenken. Einer davon ist OSCE oder OSZE, sag mal, glaube ich, auf Deutsch.
Ist die, ja, Exchange Union.
Organisationen für Sicherheit und Zusammenarbeit in Europa. Genau. Und da gibt es das ODIHR, das Office for Democratic Institutions and Human Rights. Das ist so eine der großen Organisationen weltweit, die hauptsächlich im europäisch-amerikanischen Raum so...
Und Afrika...
.und Afrika Wahlbeobachtung macht.
Ja, die werden auch regelmäßig aus Weißrussland ausgewiesen, war es nicht so?
Ja, die rechnen in Europa rechnen bis Russland mit rein. Und die haben da sieben Schlüsselwörter mal aufgeschrieben. Universal, Equal, Fair, Secret, Free, Transparent and Accountable. Also, wie auch immer man das auf Deutsch besetzen würde.
Universal, Gleich, Fair, Geheim, Freit, Transparent und Nachvollziehbar.
Genau.
Und da trügt ja schon mal die Hälfte aus dem Stand nicht zu auf die amerikanischen Wahlen.
Ja, kann man, kann man, aber was, was wichtig ist, ist, dass die auch, es ist nicht ein Eintagsding. Man guckt nicht nur auf, auf den Wahltag richtig gut hin, sondern es ist, es geht um die ganze Umgebung der Wahl.
Also auch, was in den Medien passiert zum Beispiel.
Auch, was in den Medien passiert. Gibt es da gleiche Zugriff auf den Medien? Ist die Wahlorganisation ehrlich gelaufen? Wie ist das mit Kandidatstellungen?
Können alle Leute wählen, die wählen wollen und so?
Genau, die ganzen Fragen müssen auch im Vorfeld geklärt sein.
Tja, und nun haben Sie, Herr Texas?
Na Moment, also ich finde eine Sache sehr erwähnenswert. Eine Sache, also Free haben wir jetzt mit frei übersetzt, aber gerade war ich ja bei dieser Sache, dass es Geld kostet wählen zu gehen, weil du eben Verdienstausfall hast. Da gibt es noch eine Sache zu zu erwähnen, nämlich war das eine der ersten Methoden, wie man die Schwarzen nach der Sklavenbefreiung am Wählen gehindert hat. Da gab es dann nämlich so Entwürfe für Gesetze, dass du nur wählen darfst, wenn du einen gewissen Mindesteinkommen hast pro Jahr. Also die waren schon versucht ihre Eliten aufrecht zu halten und das hat gedauert und gekostet, diese Scheiße wegzukriegen. Und genau dieselbe Art von Unterdrückung haben wir heute wieder. Das ist eine widerliche Kontinuität von ganz furchtbaren Zeiten. Und auch Frauenwahlrecht muss ja erkämpft werden. Und das haben wir heute auch wieder, dass es Versuche gibt, die Frauen am Wählen zu hindern, weil die nämlich überwiegend Demokraten wählen. Es gab neulich so eine Statistik, die ich ja ganz furchtbar fand. Wenn nur Frauen wählen würden, würde Obama deutlich gewinnen. Und wenn nur Männer wählen dürften, würde Romney deutlich gewinnen. Wo ich mich ja frage, welche Männer wählen eigentlich Romney? So, hallo. Ja, aber so sieht das aus. Und diese Statistik muss man im Hinterkopf behalten, wenn man sich diese ganzen Problemchen anguckt, die es da gibt.
Gut, interessant an dieser US-City-Wahlbeobachtung ist, dass Texas ja gerade die richtig abschrecken will, davon da Wahlbeobachtungen durchzuführen. Und zwar hat der texanische Generalstaatsanwalt einen offenen Brief geschrieben an diese Organisation und gesagt, wenn ihr euch dem Wahllokal nähert, dann werdet ihr festgenommen und angeklagt.
Nee, er hat gesagt, dann besteht die Gefahr, dass ihr verfolgt werdet. Und zwar die Grenze war irgendwie 100 Fuß in 30 Metern. Also auf 30 Meter dem Wahllokal nähert, dann begebt ihr euch in Gefahr, hier verfolgt zu werden.
Und ich meine, das ist halt so eine Ansage, die kommt normalerweise aus Weißrussland oder so oder halt irgendwie oder sonstigen.
Und vor allem geht das hier einmal fett durch die Presse, wenn so was aus Weißrussland kommt.
Wenn man jetzt noch diese Sache googelt, diese Texas und OSZE Sache, dann findet man nur konservative Blogs, die das total gut finden, dass mal jemand Szene gezeigt hat an diese ganze United Nations und anderen Organisationen, die denken, dass sie hier in Amerika was zu sagen haben. Und no need for foreigners to watch our elections. Amerika für den Amerikaner.
Amerika, fuck yeah. Ja, das ist Teil von der republikanischen Realität, dass die United Nations eine Organisation ist, die gegründet wurde, um die Amerikaner von ihrer Freiheit zu trennen.
Nur, dass die OSZE eh nix mit der UN zu tun hat. Pssst.
Details, Details. Ich glaube, wir sind eigentlich zeitlich auch schon ziemlich am Ende. Wie kam jetzt hier noch eine Liste mit den Tricks, die wollen wir noch ein bisschen durchgehen, die es da so gibt?
Gut, also, wo wir noch reden sollten sind, ist Redshift und die anderen statistischen Anomalien. Du sagst vielleicht mal was zu Redshift denn?
Redshift ist ein Phänomen, was eigentlich ziemlich neu ist von den letzten zehn Jahren.
Das ist eigentlich aus der Physik, ne?
Redshift hängt so ein bisschen zusammen mit der Einführung von Wahlcomputern, zumindest zeitlich. Und Redshift ist das Phänomen, dass irgendwann die Exit-Polls, also die die meisten...
Was ist eine Exit-Poll? Das müssen wir zuerst erklären.
Also gibt es in Deutschland auch eine Exit-Poll, die ist die Wählerbefragung beim Verlassen des Wahllokals. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht haben es einige von euch schon mal erlebt. Also ich hab's schon ein paar Mal gesehen, auch beim Wahlbeobachten. Da stehen dann halt am Ausgang vom Wahllokal, da stehen dann meistens von AD oder ZDF beauftragte Befrager, von so Umfrageinstituten. Und die haben eine Liste, auf der bestimmte demografische Zusammenstellung stehen. Und dann müssen die, keine Ahnung, in jedem Wahllokal, neben sie stehen, befragen sie dann halt 30 Leute, die irgendwie 50 bis 65 und irgendwie männlich-weiblich gleichverteilt sind und Jüngere und so weiter, je nachdem, wie die Demografie aussieht, was sie dann gewählt haben. Und das funktioniert in Deutschland zumindest so, zumindest die, wo ich beobachtet habe, wo erzählt ist, dass es auch anders ist, dass man quasi noch so eine Art zweiten Wahlzettel kriegt, den man dann halt in die Urne schmeißt, die da bei denen steht. Also man muss sozusagen nicht offenbaren, was man da gesagt hat, sondern das wird halt sozusagen anonym befragt.
Aber Exit-Polls sind schon die goldene Standard für das Beurteilen, ob ein Wahl noch ehrlich ist.
Genau, und dieser Exit-Poll in Deutschland funktioniert halt so, dass durch die demographische Zusammensetzung, die dem Durchschnitt der Wähler entspricht, man halt einen statistischen Schnitt durch die Wahl bekommt, der, wenn er gut gemacht ist, halt sehr, sehr nah an dem eigentlichen Ergebnis ist. Also typischerweise sind so die Abweichungen zwischen Exit-Polls und den in Deutschland und dem Wahlergebnis weit unter 5 Prozent so. Also es nimmt interessanterweise in den letzten Jahren zu, aber sind halt eher nicht so signifikant.
Aber was jetzt passiert ist, dass in Amerika das Exit-Poll immer mehr in demokratische Richtungen schiebt im Vergleich zu das wirkliche Wahlergebnis.
Also mehr Leute sagen, sie haben demokratisch gewählt, obwohl das Wahlergebnis was anderes dahinter ist.
Und dann ist jetzt die Frage natürlich, gibt es ein mysteriöses Phänomen, was die Exit-Polls irgendwie verschiebt? Oder gibt es ein mysteriöses Phänomen, was das Wahlergebnis verschiebt?
Weißt du, wie die Exit-Polls in den USA laufen? Sind die auch anonym oder sind die...
Die sind anonym.
Das heißt, die haben das von den TV-Netzen gemacht?
Naja, ich weiß das nicht. Ich habe sie sowohl anonym als auch, glaube ich, auch nicht anonym gesehen übrigens.
Okay, weil ich meine, wäre möglich, dass es den Leuten peinlich ist, für Romney gestimmt zu haben oder für Bush.
Naja, es ist in Amerika nicht so, wie zum Beispiel hätte man hier NPD gewählt. Und es nimmt zu, es ist in den letzten zehn Jahren plötzlich komplett aus der Ruder gelaufen. Und jetzt wird also der Redshift wirklich aus dem Exit-Poll weg korrigiert, korrigiert zwischen Anführungsstrichen, um hochrechnen zu können für Fernsehen am Election Night.
Das heißt also, die Medienorganisationen, die die Exit-Polls durchführen, korrigieren, also gehen davon aus, dass ihre Exit-Polls falsch sind und einen Gewichtungsfaktor brauchen, damit sie hinterher das offizielle, wahrscheinlich gefälschte Wahlergebnis treffen.
Ja. Aber das wird jetzt gelöst, dadurch, dass es dieses Jahr richtig weniger Exit-Polls gibt.
Irgendwie in 19 Staaten nicht oder sowas.
Ja, genau. Es wird nur noch ganz wenig Exit-Polls gemacht und gar nicht mehr so breit. Und die werden als viel weniger wichtig präsentiert. Und das hat auch damit zu tun, dass es Early-Voting gibt und Absentee-Ballots und Vote-by-Mail. Also, dass es auch immer mehr Stimmen nicht mehr am Wahltag selber abgegeben werden.
Da haben die Demokraten auch zu aufgerufen, dass man Early-Voting machen soll, um zu verhindern, dass man da mit Catecholissen aufgehalten wird. Die langen Schlangen auch, aber eben auch, um zu verhindern, dass du da in eine von diesen Problemen am Wahltag läufst.
Dann ist uns noch bei der Recherche so eine Geschichte untergekommen. Es gibt noch eine andere interessante statistische Anomalität und zwar haben wir da ein Paper gefunden, wo wir uns noch nicht so ganz im Klaren darüber sind, inwieweit es jetzt vollständig zutrifft. Aber es sieht so aus, als wenn Romney in Counties, die groß sind, also wo viele Wähler in dem County sind, überproportional mehr Stimmen bekommt. So was halt irgendwie eine Indikation dafür sein könnte, wenn man es bös für dich interpretiert, dass dort halt irgendwie entweder Wahlcomputer oder andere Betrug oder Da kann man mehr Stimmen umkippen, ohne dass es auffällt. Genau, oder halt Betrug im Zusammenhang mit dem Zusammenzählen der Stimmen, der auch in Software passiert, die wiederum von Firmen geliefert wird, die mehrheitlichen republikanischer Hand sind. Ob das da halt offensichtlich oder wahrscheinlich Betrug passiert, der sich eben dadurch äußert, dass man da, wenn man diese Kurven, also wir tun den Link auch in die Show Notes, dann könnt ihr euch das selber mal angucken und vielleicht auch mal, vielleicht könnt ihr einen Statistiker unter den Hörern mal was dazu sagen, ob da Sachen übersehen wurden. Also ich hab mit irgendwie zwei Leuten geredet, die so ein bisschen sich mit Statistik auskennen und die beide meinten, so er sieht halt irgendwie solide aus und es sieht halt irgendwie so aus, als wäre da offensichtlich, ja also wäre das halt ganz merkwürdig, also dass da Rom-Nemeyer-Stimmen in einen großen Count, die es bekommt als ein Kleinen. Rob ist davon nicht so überzeugt, weil er meint, das Wahlsystem ist viel zu chaotisch.
Das ist so die alte, es gibt, das ist ein wunderbares Argument gegen 9-Eleven immer, aber so ein großes Geheimnis kann man noch gar nicht mit so viel mitwissern, das geht doch gar nicht.
Naja, ich muss hoch überzeugt werden, aber naja, es sieht halt einfach die Grafiken, die dazugehören, sehen zu clean aus. Da würde man nicht erwarten, dass das so komplett clean ist. Aber ich will es auch vielleicht glauben, ich möchte es gerne mal sehen.
Okay, also wir warten da mal auf eure Kommentare. Wir haben ja bestimmt genügend Statistik unter unseren Hörern. Dann sind wir mal gespannt, was da irgendwie an den Punkt kommt.
Man merkt in ganz Europa, zumindest ich merke das in Holland, und ich merke es auch in Deutschland, dass viele Sachen immer mehr nach Amerika aussehen. Auch in den Wahlen, das ist amerikanisiert, alles so ein bisschen. In Deutschland gibt es auch Gerrymandering. Da hat es hier mal eine PDS-Geschichte in Berlin gegeben, wo sie dann Ost- und Westbezirke zusammengetan haben, um PDS.
Damit die weniger Stimmen kriegen?
Nein, damit die nicht für Überhang oder für Extramandate, damit die da keinen Zugriff darauf hatten.
Und sie wollten Dreckkandidaten verhindern.
Ja, so was.
Der Name ist übrigens ganz witzig. Der kommt von Salamander und Gerry. Gerry hieß der erste Typ, der das angewendet hat. Und er hat halt so einen Wahlbezirk gemacht, der nicht eben so ein Kreis war, wie es üblich war, sondern so ein Salamander, der sich da durch die Gegend gekrönt hat daher der Name.
Aber sowohl in Holland als auch in Deutschland gibt es jetzt bei euch das Kanzler-Duell. Bei uns ist das die Frage, wer jetzt Premierminister wird. Und da viele Wähler entscheiden sich dann am letzten Moment um auf einer der zwei größten Parteien, um quasi strategisch Einfluss darauf auszuüben, wer dann Kanzler oder Premierminister wird. Also es gibt bei uns zumindest immer mehr Einfluss vom Geld. Bei uns gibt es da ein paar Lücken im Parteifinanzierungsgesetz, wodurch politische Bewegungen, die noch keine Partei sind zum Beispiel, dürfen geheimes Geld haben, egal wo es herkommt.
Willes ist eine Partei mit einem Mitglied oder wie war das?
Willes ist eine Partei mit einem Mitglied. Nur Willes selber und weil kein Partei hat nur Bewegung, darf der Geld von egal wo haben und muss auch nicht deklarieren.
Wo wollen es die anderen Parteien dann nicht fixen?
Das Geld kommt dann wohl aus Amerika und aus Israel. Ja, aber das ist alles so ein bisschen, das dauert jetzt lange und wir hatten eigentlich nie ein gutes Parteifinanzierungsgesetz wie in Deutschland. Das kommt jetzt erst so. Aber immer mehr amerikanisiert, zumindest bei uns und auch bei euch in den Wahlen. Und ich glaube, nach heute müsste man sich fragen, ob das vielleicht......
nicht so eine gute Idee ist.
Naja, suboptimal ist vielleicht.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
So, bevor du jetzt Schluss machst, möchte ich hier noch ganz kurz die Sachen, die wir versprochen hatten, aber die wir nicht geliefert haben, weil wir das machen jeden Scheiß, dann kommen wir gleich zu, dann kommen wir nicht zu. In Arizona gibt es so ein Ding, dass sie ganz viele illegal immigrants als Thema aufgefasst haben. Das hat nicht nur damit zu tun, dass sie da viele illegal immigrants haben, sondern das ist die neue Rhetorikwähle der Republikaner, dass sie einfach behaupten, dass die würden dann wählen, obwohl sie gar nicht wählen dürfen. Und die Latinos wählen mit großer Mehrheit Obama. Das heißt, das ist eigentlich auch eher ein Wahlbetrugsding. Es gibt allerdings jetzt schon einen Straftatbestand dafür, zu wählen, wenn man nicht darf. Und es ist noch nie vorgekommen, dass da irgendjemand verhaftet wurde. Deswegen insofern...
Ja, weil der würde in einen Knast gehen.
Der würde in einen Knast gehen, genau, deswegen macht das niemand.
Wurde rausgeschmissen werden.
Das ist komplett Bullshit. Die ganze Idee ist komplett Bullshit. So, dann haben wir gesagt, voter ID-Laws. Da haben wir erklärt, die Angulkaner haben keinen Personalausweis. Einen Detail haben wir aber noch nicht erklärt, was man stattdessen nimmt, wenn man sich anmeldet auf dieses Voter-Registration-Ding, ist, dass man seinen Führerschein hinlegt. Das ist da der Personalausweisersatz.
Oder den Gun Permit.
Oder ein Gun Permit. Das kommt auf Bundesland an. Aber das Problem ist eben, Führerschein kostet Geld, Auto kostet Geld und viele von den Ärmsten der Armen, insbesondere so Schwarze in innerstädtischen Bezirken, haben halt kein Auto, weil das lohnt sich auch nicht in so einer Stadt und es kostet halt Geld. Und dadurch haben die auch oft keinen Führerschein. Das heißt, das ist auch ein Bias, der nicht sofort offensichtlich ist.
Da gab es doch diesen großartigen Spot von Sarah Silverman, eine amerikanische Komediantin, also eine der Bekannteren, die genauer gesagt hat, naja, gut, also ihr könnt euch zwar keinen Führerschein leisten, aber so ein Gun-Permit, also ein Waffenschein, kostet fast nichts. Und vor allen Dingen macht es den anderen mehr Angst, wenn ihr euch jetzt ein Gun-Permit holt, als wenn ihr euch jetzt ein Führerschein holt. Also holt euch ein Gun-Permit, damit ihr wieder gehen könnt.
Ja, also ich meine, es ist immer so ein Katz-und-Maus-Spiel. Also die Reaktion, dass man halt den Führerschein nimmt und dass es da Probleme gibt, ist, dass die Demokraten eben dazu aufgerufen haben, dass die Leute alle sich registrieren sollen. Und das durfte traditionell alle möglichen Organisationen, durften das machen. ACORN zum Beispiel durfte das machen. Falls es jemand mal sagt, da gab es da einen großen Skandal, den die Republikaner im Wesentlichen inszeniert haben, um ACORN platt zu hauen. Aber auch so Frauenrechtsorganisationen haben diese Anmeldung entgegengenommen. Und daraufhin haben die republikanischen Staaten eben angefangen dagegen zu steuern, indem sie Gesetze gemacht haben, die es verboten haben, dass man z. B so einen Zettel später als 48 Stunden nach dem Ausfüllen einreicht, was ja total blödsinnig ist. Was soll denn daran jetzt irgendwie schlimm sein? Oder dass man große Strafen verhängt hat, wenn da ein Taipo drauf ist, wofür die einreichende Organisation nichts kann. Aber diese Art von Gesetzen hat eben dazu geführt, dass die Anzahl der Stellen, die diese Registrierungen entgegengenommen sind, rapide runtergegangen sind. Und es hat natürlich wieder genau die Falschen getroffen. Und quasi die letzte Stelle, bei der das immer ging, sind halt die Führerscheinausgabestellen. Aber das ist halt eine staatliche Einrichtung. Und die Republikaner stehen ja darauf, den Staat zu verkleinern und aus Budgetgründen irgendwie Sachen zuzumachen, die überflüssig sind. Und da sind dann halt auch gerne mal die Öffnungszeiten von diesen Dingern drunter gefallen. Also für die meisten von diesen Sachen kann man sich auch Erklärungen ausmalen, die nicht wahlbetrug sind, aber es fällt halt schwer in der Masse. Die Challenges haben wir gehabt, den Voterdrive haben wir gehabt.
Also eigentlich haben wir alles gehabt.
Den Rest haben wir, glaube ich, gehabt.
Ja, genau.
Ach so, Moment, den Arbeitgeber, das war schon ziemlich Hammer. Also es gab ja die Geschichte, dass Industrielle ihren Mitarbeitern quasi gesagt haben, wenn ihr nicht Romney wählt, dann fliegt ihr alle raus.
Genau, dann kürzen wir Jobs.
Und das ist natürlich verboten. Also das ist richtig verboten. Da gibt es ein echtes Gesetz gegen, was genau das untersagt. Man darf nicht sein, das hat sie einfach nicht geschert.
Genau wie in Ohio, wo das Election Board eine......
hat Zettel geschickt, die Wahl ist am 8. Und die Wahl ist tatsächlich am 6. Wenn du am 8. hingehst, ist es zu spät.
Das war immer schon ein Trick.
Das gibt es schon länger.
Das gibt es eben schon länger, aber das war dann immer so ein anonyme Sender.
Aber das Election Board machte nicht...
Aber jetzt war es das Election Board.
Das ist schon richtig.
Also eigentlich die Wahlbehörde, das wäre ungefähr so, als wenn euch hier die Meldestelle einen Zettel schickt, auf dem steht irgendwie die Wahl.
Da müsst ihr euch in Brasilien einfinden.
Zwei Tage später oder ihr müsst ins Annovalokal.
Das sind so die Sachen, mit denen man da zu kämpfen hat.
Dann wollten wir noch den Buchtipp loswerden. Das war deiner.
Buchtipp, ja. Also da gibt es eine Reihe von Büchern von Greg Pallast, den ich immer nur komplett empfehlen kann. Das aktuelle von ihm geht komplett um Wahlbetrug, heißt Billionaire Send Ballot Bandits. Das habe ich selber noch nicht gelesen, aber die davor kann ich alle empfehlen. Da gibt es zum Beispiel The Best Democracy Money Can Buy, was ich einfach schon einen so schönen Spruch finde, dass ich ihn auch gelingt, ich mal im Blog verwende. Also das werden wir auch verlinken. Das sind schöne Bücher.
Ja gut, dann sind wir damit am Ende. Vielen Dank an Rop.
Gerne.
Für die ausführliche Vorbereitung und Teilnahme.
In diesem Sinne, vote early, vote often.
Vote early, vote often. Falls ihr irgendwie wählen könnt, dann seht zu, dass eure Stimme auch tatsächlich gezählt wird in der amerikanischen Wahlen. Ansonsten, falls ihr Lust habt, da gibt es noch diesen Flatter-Button, auf den ihr drücken könnt. Ansonsten freuen wir uns tatsächlich insbesondere über Feedback von Statistikern zu diesem interessanten Phänomen. Ansonsten dann, bis zum nächsten Mal.